GOOD MORNING TO
ALL- WELCOME TO THE JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
AND THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS I AM
PATRICK ALL CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
MISTER RAMOS IS CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS
AFFAIRS. AND MISTER MEDIAN ALSO
JOINS US TODAY OTHERS MAY JOIN
US AS WELL MR MEDINA IS CHAIR
OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND IN THE ASSEMBLY
SO AGAIN GOOD MORNING- I AM
CALLING THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING TO ORDER ON THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
CURRICULUM AND STUDENT SUCCESS
THAT IS OUR TOPIC TODAY. THIS
HEARING IS JOINTLY SPONSORED
AGAIN BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON IT ON THE EDUCATION AND THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE. ON
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS AND I
WANT TO WELCOME MR OF RAMOS-
FOR HIS PRESENCE HERE TODAY AND
HE'S GOING TO START US OFF WITH
THE LAND OF KNOWLEDGE BUT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT BEFORE WE MOVE
ON. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THIS IS A LANDING
KNOWLEDGE MINT FOR THE AREA
THAT WE'RE IN AND CONDUCT IN
THIS BUSINESS AND WE WANT TO
GIVE LAND IT KNOWLEDGE MEANT TO
THE ME WHAT PEOPLE. LISTEN AND
PEOPLE IN THE PARTY WHEN PEOPLE
FROM ACROSS THE SACRAMENTO
RIVER. FOR THEIR TERRITORY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I THANK
YOU MR ROSE- BEFORE BEGIN
WHETHER CHEN I HAVE A STATEMENT
TO READ REGARDING OUR PROCESS
TODAY. THE ASSEMBLY IS
REQUIRING THAT MASS BE WORN BY
ALL PEOPLE PRESENT MY ALL ALL
THOSE PRESENT IN THE HEARING
ROOM. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE
AMASSED WE WILL PROVIDE ONE FOR
YOU IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE T
INVITE PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU MAY
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE WHEN WE
INVITE. COMMENT FROM PEOPLE IN
THE ROOM THAT'S WHEN WE DO
THAT. CAPE WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE LIMITED
TO ONE MINUTE PER PERSON AND
WILL BE LIMITED. TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES OVERALL TOTAL. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO.
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IN THE ON THE
SCREEN THERE. IF YOU GO TO THE
WEBSITE. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN.
PLEASE LISTEN IF YOU'RE CALLING
ON THE- PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS
WE REACH THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF THIS HEARING. LET
YOU KNOW WHEN IT'S TIME TO CALL
IN. TO GET PUBLIC COMMENT- FOR
THOSE- THE WHO ARE NOT
PRESENTING. PLEASE FOLLOW THE
MODERATORS INSTRUCTIONS THE
ELIMINATE ALL BACK ON I'LL BE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THAT'S
KEY. THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES. OTHERWISE WE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU
THEY'LL JUST BE TOO MUCH NOISE.
AND IT WILL NOT WORK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
916-319-2087 THERE IS ALSO
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION IN
CAPITOL PARK ON THE NORTH
STEPS. OF THE CAPITOL. THE THE
COMMITTEE ALSO ACCEPTS WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
PORTAL. ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. AND ANY DISRUPTIONS.
OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
HEARING PROCESS WILL NOT BE
TOLERATED- SO WITH THAT- WHAT
WE START WITH JUST SOME OPENING
REMARKS HERE. ALL THIS MAKE A
FEWAND ALL TERMS TO RAMOS AND
THEN MISTER MEDINA- AS ONE
THANK MYSTERON MOST FOR
PROMPTING THIS HEARING TODAY-
HE'S- YOU KNOW VERY STRONG
PROPONENT OF THE- THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY FOR SURE BUT ALSO THE
KIDS IN THE COMMUNITY. AND
THAT'S KIND OF OUR TOPIC TODAY
IS- HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT OUR
NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH ARE
SUCCESSFUL ON THE EDUCATIONAL
FRONT- AND OTHER KIDS ARE MADE
AWARE OF- THE NATIVE AMERICAN
EXPERIENCE IN CALIFORNIA SO
WITH THAT I'M GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO OUR MISTER ROBINSON
THANK HIM AGAIN FOR PROMPTING
TODAY'S HEARING. MR ROSS THANK
YOU THANK YOU SURE WELL DONALD-
FOR THOSE KIND WORDS HELLO
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
ALL OF YOUR COLLABORATION AND
MAKING THIS HEARING- COME TO
FRUITION. CERTAINLY IT'S A
TOPIC THAT WARRANTS DISCUSSION-
AND SIT IN THE LEGISLATURE WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD IN
ENGAGING IN THESE TYPES OF
DISCUSSIONS- THE CERTAINLY
WE'VE SEEN HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EXAMPLES OF WHY-
THIS TYPE OF- EDUCATION ALL-
AWARENESS OF WHAT THEY WERE
DOING HERE WITH THE HEARING.
NEEDS TO BE DONE AND JUST
RECENTLY THERE WAS A SITUATION
THAT THAT HAPPENED IN- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA'S DISTRICT THAT I
THINK I'M THROUGH THE CHAIR IF
I COULD- GO AHEAD AND ALLOWS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA. TO
COMMENT ON THAT SITUATION.
THANK YOU ARE YOUR RAMOS AND J.
OF. I DO WANNA. THE STORY OF
THE RECENT INCIDENT. THAT
OCCURRED IN MY DISTRICT. A
RIVERSIDE THE LAST WEEK LAST
WEEK THAT IS FUNDAMENTAL. TO
WHAT WE ARE DISCUSSING HERE
TODAY. LAST WEEK AT ONE OF OUR
LOCAL HIGH SCHOOLS A
MATHEMATICS TEACHER WAS
TEACHING A LESSON. WHERE SHE
INCLUDED ON THE MONIC DEVICE.
THE TEACHER BEGAN TO IMITATE
NATIVE AMERICANS TO THE POINT
THAT A STUDENT THE CLASS. WHO
FELT UNCOMFORTABLE BEGAN
RECORDING THE INCIDENT. AT THE
TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ADVANTAGES AND
HI ALL CONDEMN THE TEACHER'S
BEHAVIOR WHICH WAS HIGHLY
INAPPROPRIATE AND OFFENSIVE. I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THIS MORNING
HOWEVER THAT THIS ISN'T THIS IS
AND WAS NOT AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT. THIS WAS NOT THE
FIRST TIME THAT THIS PARTICULAR
TEACHER DEMONSTRATED THE SAME
BEHAVIOR. PICTURES OF THE YEAR
IN THE YEARBOOK OF HER- WITH
HEADRESTS- FROM TEN YEARS
EARLIER. NOR WAS THIS THE FIRST
TIME IN ANY CLASSROOM WERE
NATIVE AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
REPRESENTED IN SUCH A TRITE
INACCURATE AND HARMFUL WAY.
THIS IS BENNETT ONGOING FAILURE
ACROSS THE AMERICAN SCHOOL
SYSTEM FOR GENERATIONS AND
CONTINUES TO BE A PROBLEM THAT
WE CANNOT IGNORE. I OFTENTIMES
STUDENTS ONLY EXPERIENCE OR
INTERACTION WITH INDIGENOUS
CULTURE IN THE CLASSROOM HAS
BEEN A CARTOONISH SCHOOL
MASCOT. AND AN ACCURATE OR
EUROCENTRIC ACCOUNT OF HISTORY
THAT'S GOOD. NOT ONLY HAS THIS
PREVENTED STUDENTS FROM HAVING
A RICHER MORE ACCURATE
UNDERSTANDING OF OUR COMPLEX
HISTORY. BUT ALSO THE
CONSEQUENCES HAVE BEEN
ESPECIALLY HARMFUL FOR NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENTS. IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION CONDUCTED
STUDIES TO EXAMINE THE IMPACTS
OF NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT AND REPRESENTATION
IN THE CLASS IN THE CLASSROOM.
FOLLOWING THIS INVESTIGATION
THE ADMINISTRATION THE
ADMINISTRATION DECLARED A STATE
OF EMERGENCY FOR NATIVE YOUTHS
AND THEIR EDUCATION. AMONG THE
PROBLEMS INCLUDED WE'RE UNDER
ACHIEVEMENT LOW RETENTION
LIMITED EMOTIONAL SUPPORT AND
LACK OF COLLEGE PREPAREDNESS.
THOSE OBSERVATIONS WERE MADE
SEVEN YEARS AGO BUT LITTLE HAS
BEEN DONE IN THIS IN THE
SUCCEEDING TIME IN TERMS OF
REPRESENTATION OF NATIVE
CULTURE WHERE STUDENTS SUPPORT.
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I HAVE
ADVOCATED SO LONG FOR ETHNIC
STUDIES IS BECAUSE OF THE
BENEFIT IT BRINGS TO STUDENTS.
STUDIES THIS YEAR PROVED THAT
THE ACCURATE AND POSITIVE
REPRESENTATION OF CULTURES
IMPROVES ACHIEVEMENT FOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR. NOW THAT AB
ONE OH ONE HAS BEEN SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR I AM FULLY
COMMITTED THAT WE DO EVERYTHING
AS A STATE AND AS THE
LEGISLATURE. TO ENSURE THAT
INCIDENTS INCIDENTS LIKE THE
ONE LAST WEEK IN RIVERSIDE DO
NOT HAPPEN AGAIN WE DO WE MUST
DO BETTER. I LOOK FORWARD TO
THIS HEARING AND SEEING HOW WE
ADVANCE AND IMPROVE EDUCATION.
FOR NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS
AND ABOUT NATIVE AMERICANS
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- MEDINA FOR-
FOR ALLOWING US TO CONTINUE TO
UNDERSTAND WHY WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO FURTHER DISCUSS NOT
ONLY CALIFORNIA INDIAN CULTURE-
IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM BUT ALL
NATIVE AMERICAN CULTURE AND THE
TEACHINGS THAT ARE GOING ON-
CERTAINLY THESE INCIDENTS
pOR DISRESPECT TOWARDS. THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE AND ALL
NATIVE AMERICANS THROUGHOUT THE
NATION WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WERE HOME.
TO MORE- NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATION IN ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE NATION BUT YET WORKING-
TO ENSURE THAT OUR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER LIKE WE ARE TODAY WITH
THIS JOINT HEARING AND BRINGING
FORWARD. THOSE AREAS ARE STILL
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED- WE LOOK
FORWARD. TO WORKING AND THEN
WITH THE HISTORY OF THE STATE
AND WITH THE WHOLE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM NOT JUST TODAY BUT WHAT
HAS LED TO THE CREATION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ULTIMATELY
FROM THE EARLY EXPLORATIONS TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE
KNOW TODAY AND WHAT WE CALL
CALIFORNIA TODAY AND THE
TREATMENT TOWARDS CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST PEOPLE THROUGH THAT
WHOLE- EXPLORATION THE
COLONIZATION UP TO WHERE WE ARE
TODAY. WHICH IS STILL HAPPENING
IN THE CLASSROOMS AS FAR AS
BLATANT DISRESPECT TOWARDS THE
CULTURE THAT WAS FIRST YEAR. SO
WE CONTINUE TO WORK AT THE-
THOSE AREAS AND THE TREATMENT
TOWARDS CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE AS A HISTORY. THAT IS
STILL LACKING OF A TRUE
PORTRAYAL OF THE VOICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEW PEOPLE IN THE
SCHOOL SYSTEMS ITSELF. LOOKING
AT A TROOPER TRAIL WITHIN THE
THIRD AND FOURTH GRADE OF
LEARNING ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST PEOPLE IN YOUR OWN AREAS
AS WELL AS THE HISTORY THE
HISTORY THAT CONTINUES TO BE
TAUGHT IN THE SCHOOLS THAT WE
NOW ARE ABLE TO BRING BEFORE
FRONT TALK ABOUT. AND WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT EIGHTH GRADE IN THE
AREAS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE UNITED
STATES AND HOW THE UNITED
STATES AND SOME OF THOSE
POLICIES LED TO REIMBURSEMENT
HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FOR MALICIOUS BEING
FORMED AND READING AREAS OF
INDIAN PEOPLE IN OUR OWN AREA
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ULTIMATELY IN BED IN THE
ELEVENTH GRADE IN THE
GOVERNMENTAL SYSTEM MAKING SURE
THAT THERE'S AN INCLUSION OF
THE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS I'M
INCLUDED IN TE FEDERAL THE
STATE AT THE LOCAL. AND TRIBAL.
THESE ARE AREAS THAT ARE STILL-
NEEDING TO HAVE THAT THE VOICE
OF THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE- DOES
THESE ARE AREAS ARE GOING TO
HEAR TESTIMONY ON TODAY- DURING
OUR PRESENTERS IN THE PANEL. IN
THE THANK YOU AGAIN- CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL FOR- COMING TOGETHER
CONVENING THIS JOINT HEARING
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT AND
HISTORIC AND I WANT TO-
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THROUGH YOUR
CHAIRMANSHIP OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE THIS IS HISTORIC. TO
BRING THESE ISSUES TO LIGHT IN
THE FOREFRONT OF MOVING FORWARD
IN HOPES OF CONTINUING TO
TACKLE THESE ISSUES TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HAVE THAT VOICE AND
SUCCEED IN EDUCATION SUMMIT
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN. TERMINAL
DAHLE FOR THAT. THANK GOD.
THANK YOU A- THE GERMAN RAMOS
AND MEDINA IS FOR YOUR MEDINA
FOR YOUR COMMENTS- SO THAT WHEN
WE MOVE INTO OUR FIRST PANEL-
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND IS
DELAYED I'VE BEEN TOLD SO WE'RE
NOT GOING TO START WITH HIM
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO START
WITH- CHAIRMAN KENNETH KAHN THE
TRIBAL CHAIRMAN OF THE SANTA
YNEZ BAND OF CHUMASH INDIANS
WHO IS JOINING US FIVE WEBEX-
CHAIRMAN CON. YOU MAY RECEIVE
ALREADY. COOL STRAW PARTY NINE
HELLO AND GOOD MORNING I'M
CATCON ON THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
SENATE'S BAND OF CHUMASH
INDIANS. I WANT TO THANK
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL- CHAIRMAN
ROLLO'S IN MEMBER MEDINA FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. THE TIME IS
RIGHT FOR CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
NATIVE AMERICAN CURRICULA OUR
TRIBE SPONSORED AB FIVE FORTY
FOUR TO CREATE A CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN LANGUAGE AND
TEACHING CREDENTIAL- WE WORK
HARD TO GET THE SUPPORT OF BOTH
THE CALIFORNIA- TEACHER
CREDENTIALING COMMISSION AND
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION FOR A BI POP FORTY
FOUR WHICH WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE. I
TRIED ALSO SPONSORED AB ONE
SIXTY THREE TO EXTEND THE
NATIVE AMERICAN LANGUAGE
TEACHING CREDENTIAL- TO ALSO
INCREASE INCLUDE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN CULTURE
TEACHING CREDENTIAL IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. OUR CLUB
ALONE HAS- THREE CREDENTIAL
NATIVE AMERICAN LANGUAGE AND
CULTURE TEACHERS I WHAT WE NEED
NEXT IS WAS A CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN CURRICULUM TO COMPLETE
THE TEACHING OF NATIVE AMERICAN
LANGUAGE AND CULTURE SO IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE SPONSORED
AB SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT WITH AN
ASSEMBLY WOMAN- AND NOW STATE
SENATOR MONIQUE LIMON. TO
CREATE A CALIFORNIA NATIVE CURRICULUM ADOPTING
THE INSTRUCTIONAL INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION BY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE WITH
CONSIDERATION BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO.
REGRETTABLY AB SEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT WAS NEVER FUNDED AND
THERE HAS BEEN NO PROGRESS
STATEWIDE ON A CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN CURRICULUM
UNTIL HOPEFULLY THIS YEAR. AND
THIS YEAR THE AB ONE SIXTY
SEVEN BUDGET TRAILER BILL-
BUDGET OF ONE POINT TWO MILLION
FOUR FOUR MODEL CURRICULUM FOR
THREE SOUTH EAST ASIAN GROUPS.
AND NATIVE AMERICAN CURRICULUM.
IT'S UNCLEAR HOW AB ONE SIXTY
SEVEN PLANNING WILL BE
ALLOCATED BUT WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT- CALIFORNIA TRIBES WILL
GIVE ME. FOR THAT FUNDING- ALL
OF THIS IS GOING ON AS EACH
TRIBE IS DEVOTED TO EDUCATING
THEIR- TRIBAL CHILDREN ARE
TRIED THAT SETTING IS BANDED TO
MATCH HAS. A DEDICATED
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT WITH
DEDICATED IN PERSON AS SOON
TUTORS FOR TEACHING ABROAD AS A
RESULT WE'RE PROUD TO ANNOUNCE
THAT WE'VE ACHIEVED A 100% HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION RATE IN OUR
SERVICE AREA. EACH OF THESE
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES THE TRIBE
HAS PLEDGED TO FULLY. FUND
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
DEGREES SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT OUR TRIBAL STUDENTS HAVE
EARNED ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
BACHELOR DEGREES. GALLUP POLL
FOUR FORTY SIX MASTER'S DEGREES
AND EIGHTY PHD OR VERY VERY
PROUD OF ALL OF OUR STUDENTS SO
WE WANT TO PLEDGE THE SUPPORT
OF THE CHUMASH BIRD BILLS BEING
DISCUSSED TODAY. WE APPRECIATE
THE ALL THE WORK THAT THIS
ELEMENT RAMOS HAS BEEN DOING TO
SUPPORT- ARE NATIVE AMERICAN
EFFORTS WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THE
THAT THE SELLER ALMOST WILL
SUCCEED- WERE AB SEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT- MAY HAVE FALLEN SHORT-
DUE TO LACK OF FUNDING. THANK
YOU I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WRITE TESTIMONY
ON THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICANS. CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
AND IN GENERAL- AND NATIVE
AMERICAN CRITICAL SPECIFICALLY.
PAKI NICE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. I'M IS
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN READY TO
TESTIFY DO WE KNOW. WE'RE TOLD
NOT YET SO WHY DON'T WE MOVE ON
AND MOVE MAYBE IF WE HAVE A-
COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR THE
CHAIRMAN I PROBABLY HAVE MORE
OF A COMMENT THAN A QUESTION-
YOU NEED CURRICULUM. AS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER THAT'S MY
BACKGROUND AS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER. BOB CERTAINLY UNIT
CURRICULUM BUT YOU ALSO NEED
RESOURCES. SO AS WE GO FORWARD-
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
THINK ABOUT WHAT WAS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER GONNA NEED
THEY WALK ANOTHER CLASSROOM IN
THE MORNING. OR THE AFTERNOON
PRIOR- IT WHEN DID TO THE DAY
THEY'RE GOING TO DELIVER THE
LASSEN AND THEY'RE PLANNING
THEIR LOSS AND WHAT THEY REALLY
NEED FROM MY PERSPECTIVE ARE
OUR RESOURCES RIGHT- BECAUSE OF
THEY'VE- GOT A REPEAT WHAT THEY
HEARD IN THIRD GRADE LIKE. IS
PROBABLY WHAT HAPPENED. IN
ABOUT GLEE WAS RIVERSIDE OR
SAMBAR DINO THAT'S NOT A GOOD
THING. HEY SO FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I JUST WANT TO
INJECT INTO THIS CONVERSATION
THE IMPORTANCE OF. ENSURING
THAT TEACHERS HAVE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES. AND BREAD THAT'S
THEY CAN GO TO A WEBSITE
WHATEVER IT IS- NOT A BOOK
REALLY. BUT THINGS THAT ENGAGE
KIDS RIGHT DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT TYPES OF- RESOURCES
THAT ENGAGE KIDS THAT THEY CAN.
THEY CAN THE KIDS CAN ACCESS.
EITHER THROUGH THEIR- THEIR
THEIR THEIR THEIR CHROMEBOOK
WHEN THEY'RE IN CLASS OR OR OR
TEACHER CAN. SHOW TO THE CLASS
OR HAND OUT TO THE CLASS PRINT
OFF EXTENDER THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS. IS UP TO DATE SHOULD
NOTICE I'VE ACTUALLY BEEN BACK
IN THE CLASS WAS NOT MUCH
PRUNING GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
WELL A LOT OF CHROMEBOOKS OUT
THERE SO THERE'S- A BIT RUNNING
AT THE SCHOOL'S BEEN DOES DROP
BY 80% PLUS. BECAUSE
EVERYTHING'S REALLY ON A
CHROMEBOOK NOMINAL AND MANY
SCHOOLS NOT ALL BUT MANY
SCHOOLS. BUT AGAIN THOSE
RESOURCES NEED TO BE AMPLY
AVAILABLE TO TEACHERS SO THAT
THEY CAN TEACH. THIS CONTENT.
IN AN APPROPRIATE MANNER. AND
THAT'S JUST FROM SOMEONE WHO'S-
YOU KNOW GONE EITHER HAD TO
LOOK FOR DIFFERENT RESOURCES
FOR DIFFERENT TYPES OF LESSONS.
AND THERE MIGHT NOT ALWAYS BE
ONE GOOD PLACE TO GO AND IF WE
GET ESTABLISH ONE GOOD PLACE TO
GO. I THINK THAT'S OUR GOAL
HERE- THAT WOULD BE A VERY GOOD
THING FROM MY PERSPECTIVE AND I
THINK. MOST CLASSROOM TEACHERS
PERSPECTIVE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISS- CHAIRMAN
DONAL- CHEN CON I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU A LOSE SOME OTHER TEACHING
MATERIALS THAT- THE CHUMASH
INDIAN AS PEOPLE HAVE CREATED-
WITHIN THE EDUCATIONAL AREA
WITHIN YOUR OWN TRY BUT ALSO
SHARING THOSE RESOURCES WITH
THE LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ABSOLUTELY I MEAN. YOU KNOW NOT
ONLY IS THE FUNDING NEEDED BUT-
OUR OUR TRANSPACIFIC WE YOU
KNOW OUR OUR DREAM IS THAT A
PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT- YOU
KNOW WOULD BE WORKING WITH
CULTURAL DEPARTMENTS- WITH OUR
LANGUAGE DEPARTMENTS AND WITH
OUR MUSEUMS- YOU KNOW THE TEN
IT'S BEEN A TWO MATCH WE'VE GOT
ALL OF THE ABOVE. AND I KNOW
THAT OTHER TRIBES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I ALSO
HAVE THOSE RESOURCES AND YOU
KNOW IDEALLY- WE DO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THOSE
DISTRICT. THIS WAY WE CAN
REALLY TEACH OUR KIDS ABOUT
THAT THE ABORIGINAL TERRITORIES
THAT THEY- THEY'RE LEARNING
WITHIN. THANK YOU- THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND SURE AND ONE OF
THE THINGS YOU MENTIONED- IS
THERE'S A 100% GRADUATION RATE
DO YOU A TEST THAT TOO- THE
CULTURAL SENSITIVITY AND THE
EDUCATION THAT COMPONENT THAT
GOES ALONG WITH THAT THAT
INCREASES THAT. ATTAINMENT WELL
YOU KNOW WE CERTAINLY HAVE A
HANDS ON- LEARNING MODEL I
WOULD LEARNING CENTER HERE ON
THE RESERVATION BUT WE ALSO
REACH OUT TO OUR STUDENTS NO
MATTER WHERE THEY ARE- WITHIN
THE STATE OR WITHIN THE NATION
AND SO- YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO
GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN ABOUT THE LANGUAGE LEARN
ABOUT THEIR CULTURE IT'S JUST
AN ADDITIONAL- LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM- BUT THAT
EXTRA SUPPORT REALLY HELPS THEM
ONCE A WEEK YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
ALWAYS A 100% ON ANNUAL BASIS
BUT THAT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
PROUD TO REPORT THAT THAT THAT
WAS OUR CURRENT. REPORT SELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
TO MR MEDINA YEP MAYBE JUST A
COMMENT- FOLLOWING UP WITH THAT
CHAIR RAMOS I THINK THE RECENT
STUDY AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY OF
FOUR YEARS AGO AND AGAIN THIS
YEAR- SHOWS EXACTLY THAT THE
DATE THE DATA- PROVES AND
SUBSTANTIATES A WHAT YOU JUST
SAID THAT STUDENTS WHO ARE
GROUNDED. IN THEIR OWN CULTURE-
THEY HAVE A SENSEOF WHO THEY
ARE AND DO MUCH MORE- ARE ARE
MUCH. APPLIED YOUR EFFORTS OUT
IN THE SANTA BARBARA VENTURA
COUNTY. THANK YOU MR MEDINA ALL
ALL HAND OVER THE GAVEL TO
MISTER RAMOS IS GOING TO
INTRODUCE OUR SECOND PANEL ON
THE SUPERINTENDENT- IS
AVAILABLE WE WILL HAVE HIM-
SHARE HIS THOUGHTS. AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THE SECOND PANEL- AND I
THINK IT SHERMAN CON FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND- MEMBERS COMMENTS
HERE ON THE DÍAS. OUR SECOND
PANEL STARTS TO MOVE INTO THE
AREAS OF NATIVE AMERICAN
CULTURE AND HISTORY IN THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
CURRICULA WE'LL HEAR FROM MERRY
LEVI CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION NATIVE
AMERICAN POCKETS SHE TEACHES IN
THE UPLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. WE WILL ALSO HEAR AND
WE'RE ALSO FORTUNATE TO HEAR
AND HAVE WITH US A
REPRESENTATIVE- FROM THE STATE
OF WASHINGTON REPRESENTATIVE
SHARON TO ME BECAUSE SANTOS
CHAIR OF THE WASHINGTON STATE
HOUSE EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND
WE ALSO ARE FORTUNATE TO HAVE
WITH US THE DISTINGUISHED
FORMER SENATOR JOHN MCCOY. HE
IS A REGISTERED MEMBER OF THE
TULALIP TRIBE IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON AND THEY WILL TALK
ABOUT THE LEGISLATION THAT
MOVED FORWARD TODAY TO. TACKLE
THE TREATMENT GAS WITH NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENTS AND SENATOR
MCCOY AUTHORED LANDMARK
LEGISLATION KNOWN AS THE SINCE
TIME IMMEMORIAL INITIATIVE OR
S. TI AND HE WILL TESTIFY VIA
WEBEX AT THIS TIME WE WILL GO
TO MERRY LEVI CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
NATIVE AMERICAN CAUCUS.
CAN YOU
HEAR ME YEAH OKAY. HI. WILL NOT
ALLOW THE GOOD MORNING TERMINAL
CHAIRMAN DRAMAS AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. NO MERRY LEVI I
AM VERY LEAVE I AM VERY HAPPY
TO BE HERE- THE ANCESTRAL LANDS
OF THE MOONWALK AND THE NAY
SUNNY AND A LOT OF PEOPLE. WHO
HAVE WALKED THESE LANDS BEFORE
US. I SPEAK TO YOU HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION CTA. WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
AN EDUCATOR'S VOICE AT TODAY'S
HEARING ON CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN CURRICULUM AND STUDENT
SUCCESS. IT IS MY HONOR TO
SERVE AS THE CHAIR OF CTAS
AMERICAN INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE
CAUCUS. AND AN ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE CTA
POLICY MAKING STEP THE STATE
COUNCIL OF EDUCATION A
GOVERNING BODY OF EIGHT HUNDRED
ELECTED CLASSROOM TEACHERS.
CTA'S ORGANIZATIONAL POLICY.
STRONGLY SUPPORTS TEACHING
STUDENTS ABOUT ANCESTRAL
LEGACIES AND THE CULTURE OF OUR
CALIFORNIAN NATIVE PEOPLE. WE
FEEL THAT IT IS IN THE CENTRAL-
IN THE STRUGGLE OF RACIAL
JUSTICE AND EQUITY. CTA
SUPPORTS PROMOTING GENUINE
RESPECT FOR INDIVIDUAL AND
CULTURAL DIVERSITY BY PROVIDING
STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A
WELL ROUNDED EDUCATION THAT
INCLUDES NATIVE AMERICAN
CURRICULUM TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
NATIVE AMERICAN CULTURAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE SHOWN THIS IN SUPPORT OF
MANY ASSEMBLY BILLS I WAS-
CHAIRMAN KHAN HAS SAID WE HAVE
A SUPPORTED ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT WHICH WAS A LOW
MOAN- MODEL CURRICULUM FOR
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES BUT HAD
NO FUNDING TO IT. AND AB ONE
SIXTY THREE THAT ALLOWED- THAT
WAS IN TEACHING CREDENTIALS FOR
ELDERS TO TEACH NATIVE CULTURE
AND LANGUAGE. AND OF COURSE THE
NINE AB NINE FORTY FIVE RAMOS
pGUARANTEED OR HELPED IN OUR
NATIVE STUDENTS WEAR THEIR
REGALIA AT GRADUATION. AND IN
THE FIGHT FOR ETHNIC STUDIES
INCLUDING NATIVE AMERICAN
CURRICULUM. THIS ENHANCES
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT IN AN
ESSENTIAL COMPONENT OF CULTURAL
DIVERSE EDUCATION. HOWEVER EVEN
THOUGH WE GIVE OUR SUPPORT AND
WE CONTINUE TO FIND WE CONTINUE
TO FIND EDUCATORS. NEEDING TO
HAVE ACCURATE INFORMATION A
CURRICULUM TO PRESENT TO THEIR
STUDENTS. THESE ARE ALL A SMALL
STEP IN ACHIEVING A VERY LARGER
PICTURE. TEACHERS FACE MANY
CHALLENGES FACED A FINDING-
ADEQUATE CURRICULAR RESOURCES
ON THIS ISSUE. FOR ELEMENTARY
TEACHERS WE TEACH ABOUT OUR
LOCAL NATIVE COMMUNITIES AND I
AM FORTUNATE TO HAVE LOCAL
CONNECTIONS TO ACCURATE
INFORMATION THAT I THAT DON'T
ROMANTICIZE HISTORY M.
PRESENTS. AND THE PRESENCE OF
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT I
SHARE WITH EVERYONE I CAN IN
THE SPACES I OCCUPY.
CONNECTIONS TO CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO PROVIDES
LESSONS ON THE WINDOW MAINT
WOULDN'T TWO TRIBES ON SALMON-
CAL STATE SAMBAR ANY DINO
UNIVERSITY IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
CAL SAN MANUEL BAND OF INDIANS
PROVIDE FIELD TRIP
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MY STUDENTS
TO LEARN IN A HANDS ON MANNER
ABOUT THE SERRANO PEOPLE. AND
MY OWN FATHER IN LAW ROBERT
LEVI PROVIDES OFF THEN TAKE
COOLEY OF BIRD SONGS THREE CDC
RECORDED BEFORE HIS PASSING.
THESE CURRICULAR RESOURCES
DEVELOPED IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR NATIVE THE IMMINENT
CALIFORNIA NATIVE TRIBES SHOULD
BE WIDELY DISTRIBUTED AND
FUNDED FOR ALL TEACHERS TO HAVE
FREE ACCESS TO THEM. RESEARCH
SHOWS OFFERING OF FINTECH
ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM IN IS
A CENTRAL COMPONENT FOR A
CULTURALLY DIVERSE AT EDUCATION
ENHANCING STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
AND IN MY OWN EXPERIENCE AS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER. STUDENTS
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED AUTHENTIC
CURRICULUM THEY ARE MORE
ENGAGED IN LEARNING AND LEARN
UNDERSTANDING NATIVE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA
MINISTRY TO PROCESS FOR
REVIEWING ALL ACADEMIC CONTENT
STANDARDS NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
INCLUSIVENESS OF NATIVE
AMERICAN CURRICULUM THROUGH OUT
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH TWELFTH
GRADE. TIM STEELE AT BIG PINE
HIGH TEACHES NATIVE AMERICAN
HISTORY BECAUSE HE KNOWS HIS
STUDENT OF THE PAIUTE AND
SHOSHONE DESCENT WANT TO LEARN
THEIR HISTORY WHICH INCLUDES
THE ALICE PIPER AND BIG PINE
COURT CASE THAT ALLOWED NATIVE
STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA TO
ATTEND CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. TODAY THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTRACT AND
RETAIN CALIFORNIAN NATIVE
AMERICANS INTO THE TEACHING
PROFESSION. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
MORE THE MORE OUR STANDARDS
REFLECT APPROPRIATE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN CURRICULUM THE
MORT STAR STUDENTS BECOME
ENGAGED IN OUR EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM. AND THEREFORE WOULD BE
WANT TO TEACH THE CURRICULUM
THAT TELLS THEIR ACCURATE
HISTORY AND CULTURE OF WHO THEY
ARE. IN CLOSING I AM ONE OF
HUNDREDS OF DEDICATED TEACHERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WE STRIVE TO
PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS
APPROPRIATE AND ACCURATE ACCESS
TO NATIVE AMERICAN CURRICULUM.
WITH LIMITED CURRICULAR
RESOURCES CALIFORNIA TODAY HAS
A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO FULFILL
ITS OBLIGATION TO CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES YOUR
ENCOURAGEMENT OF COLLABORATION
AND FUNDING TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES WITHIN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEMS WILL BENEFIT ALL
STUDENTS. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE A SCHOOLING. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU VERY LEVI- FOR
SPEAKING UP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE
TO WORK AND TO FURTHER OUR
PEOPLE- WITH AN EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU
TO IF YOU COULD STATE A SEAT AT
WHERE YOU'RE AT- WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM THE- STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION A MISTER TONY
THURMOND IF HE'S AVAILABLE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU A CHAIRMAN
RAMOS THANK YOU- CHAIRMAN-
DODDLE- SORRY FOR A DELAY AND
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO JOIN YOU. TODAY
I JOIN YOU- FROM TONGA BY LAND-
AT- DAYTON ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
ARE THE HOME OF THE DRAGONS. IN
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE'RE REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF EVENTS TODAY TO
PROMOTE BAXEEN OUT REACH AND
AWARENESS. AND TO CONTINUE THE
STATE OPENING OF OUR SCHOOLS.
IT IS TRULY AN HONOR. TO FOLLOW
THE REMARKS OF CHAIRMAN CON-
AND OF. MARY LEVI WHO I
CONSIDER TO BE ONE OF THE
PREMIER- EDUCATORS. OF NATIVE
AMERICAN HISTORY- IN OUR STATE
PERHAPS IN OUR NATION. I WANT
TO THANK- THE JOINT COMMITTEES
FOR HOLDING TODAY'S
CONVERSATION. ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF NATIVE AMERICAN CULTURE AND
HISTORY. IN OUR SCHOOLS AND I
WANT TO THANK. YOU AS A MEMBER
ROB MOST AND MARY LEVI AND
OTHERS WHO'VE JOINED US IN
SHARING THE RICH HISTORY OF THE
FIRST PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD IN
OUR EDUCATION. TO AN EIGHT
SERIES WHERE WE- TALK ABOUT THE
AND OF COUNTERING THE THAT ARE
TAUGHT IN OUR SCHOOLS ABOUT
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE THEY'RE
OFTEN IN FACTUAL INFLAMMATORY.
STEREO TYPICAL AND REINFORCE
HARMFUL MESSAGES ABOUT THE
FIRST PEOPLE IN OUR STATE I
THANK YOU FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS TO MERRY BE BY AND OTHERS
WHO JOINED US IN OUR
CONVERSATION. ABOUT ETHNIC
STUDIES- PROUD TO HAVE BEEN A
CO SPONSOR OF AB ONE OH ONE TO
MAKE ETHNIC STUDIES A
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT. I'M
GRATEFUL TO HAVE MANY LIKE
NEARLY NINE OTHERS WHO WORK
WITH US TO LOOK FOR WAYS TO
HONE IN ON THE PROPER
MESSAGING- FOR ETHNIC STUDIES.
CURRICULUM GUIDE SO THAT OUR
SCHOOLS HAVE A GREAT REFERENCE.
TO WORK FROM IT IS TRUE- THAT-
A NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES HAS
BEEN TAKEN UP IN THE HISTORY OF
SOCIAL SCIENCES FRAMEWORK GOING
BACK TO TWENTY SIXTEEN- BUT
MANY HAVE POINTED OUT TO US.
THAT THAT. NEEDS A REFRESH-
THAT THERE ARE UNFORTUNATELY A
PLACES WHERE THERE ARE- EIGHT
PIECES OF HISTORY THAT ARE NOT
ACCURATE IN WORK THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE. AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE
SO GRATEFUL A TO USE A MEMBER
ALMOST FOR YOUR AUTHORSHIP OF
AB ONE FIVE FIVE FOUR NACA SIX.
AND WHY WE AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ARE
PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR OF THAT
BILL WE BELIEVE THAT. A NEW
AMERICAN CHILDREN WILL BENEFIT
FROM LEARNING THE RICH HISTORY
OF THEIR ANCESTORS IN THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT THEY MADE TO
THE STATE WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
ALL STUDENTS IN OUR STATE WILL
BENEFIT. FROM LEARNING ABOUT
THE HISTORY AND CONTRIBUTIONS
OF THE FIRST PEOPLE AND SO- WE
STAND READY TO HELP IN ANY WAY
THAT WE CAN. WE KNOW THAT WE
ALSO MUST DO WHAT WE CAN
SUPPORT CLOSING THE LEARNING
GAP FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
INCLUDING NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS AND WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE WORK TO DO TO GET IT
PASSED. A 75% GRADUATION RATE
I'M TO GET PASS OF CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM THAT WE KNOW HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED.
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS AS IT
HAS A THANK. AFTER AMERICANS
DID. AT IT HAS AFFECTED MANY OF
IMMIGRANT AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WE CAN TO DOING THE
WORK. YOU ARE- EFFORTS TO
INCREASE READING LEVELS IN OUR
STATE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS LEARN TO READ BY THIRD
GRADE. TO PROMOTE BY LITERACY-
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THESE WILL
BE BENEFICIAL TO ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES- YEAH AND- WE-
PLEDGED OUR RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT IT. WE'RE SUPPORTING A
NUMBER OF NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE WHERE WE PROVIDE A
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR SUPPORTING
TUTORING. AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
COACHING AND MENTORING AND I'M
EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE THAT WE
RECONSTITUTED THE AMERICAN
INDIAN EDUCATION OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE- TO HAVE- TWO DOZEN
PLUS REPRESENTATIVES. OF
CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE TRIBES
HELPING TO GUIDE OUR WORK AND
PARTNERSHIP- WITH THE NATIVE
COMMUNITY ON WAYS THAT WE CAN
BE SUPPORTER TO OUR NATIVE
STUDENTS AND TO ALL OF OUR SIX
MILLION STUDENTS- I'LL STOP
THERE BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
PREEMPT THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
MERELY BY SOME. SOME QUESTIONS
AS I HAVE FOUND HER TO BE
INFORMATIVE. AND WE'RE ALL
LEARNING FROM HER- END UP BACK
I ALSO REMAIN ON IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT WE CAN ANSWER-
ON BEHALF OF THE COMPANY
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY GIVE THIS
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS SUPER. FOR THAT THANK YOU
FOR- REINSTITUTING- THE
COMMITTEE- TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND WORK- TO GET A TRUE
PORTRAYAL CALIFORNIA INDIAN-
HISTORY. CULTURE AND CURRICULUM
AS WELL AS WORKING ON RESOURCES
SO THE TEACHERS COULD HAVE
THOSE. IN THE CLASSROOM AT THIS
TIME I'M NOT SURE IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE DÍAS
FOR THE SUPERINTENDENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA. F.
WELCOME SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN.
MADMAN OF- BUT I HAVE A
QUESTION- THE MERRY- BROUGHT UP
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'VE WORKED
ON YOURSELF- SUPERINTENDENT.
AND THAT IS OF THE DIVERSITYOF
THE OF THE TEACHING- FORCE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I LIKE
SHERMAN O'DONNELL HAS BEEN MANY
YEARS IN IN OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN THE
CLASSROOM. AND WE KNOW THAT THE
TEACHING FORCE IN CALIFORNIA
DOESN'T REFLECT- THE STUDENT
POPULATION. SO I I'M CURIOUS
AND IF ANYONE HAS ANY DATA.
NUMBERS OF HOW MANY NATIVE
AMERICAN TEACHERS WE HAVE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
HOW AND WHAT CAN WE DO TO
INCREASE THOSE NUMBERS AND SO I
WOULD MAKE THAT A QUESTION.
BOTH YOU- SUPERINTENDENT AND
TO- MERRY LEVI. IF YOU COULD.
THE SUPERINTENDENT. THANK YOU
THROUGH THE CHAIRS- AND THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA GOOD
MORNING ONE OF THE S. AND MODEL
A SOME CASSETTE-
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN ON THE ON
THE SIGNING OF AB ONE OH ONE
INTO LAW- I'LL ASK THE TEAM AT
CDP USE ALSO MONITORING THIS
WEAPON ARE TO IDENTIFY IF WE
HAVE ANY DATA ON THE PERCENTAGE
OF OUR WORKFORCE- WHO ARE-
NATIVE AMERICAN TEACHERS IN THE
MEANTIME I'LL ANSWER THE SECOND
PART YOUR QUESTION- WE DO HAVE
SOME RESOURCES THAT YOU ARE
PROVIDED THANK YOU LEGISLATORS-
OR WHAT YOU PROVIDED IN THE
GOVERNOR IN THIS- STATE BUDGET-
ABOUT A ONE AND A HALF. DOLLARS
FOR WHAT WE CALL DIVERSIFYING
THE TEACHER WORKFORCE AND WE
WILL BE WORKING TO- DO MORE
WORK TO RECRUIT MORE EDUCATORS
OF COLOR- AND WE LIKE TO WORK
WITH- I TRY TO COMMUNITY
LEADERS ON HOW WE MIGHT- A
SUPPORT THAT RECRUITMENT- THAT
COULD INCLUDE. MANY THINGS
INCLUDING SCHOLARSHIPS.
RESIDENCY PROGRAM IN COACH. WE
HAVE THE RESOURCES WE NOW NEED
TO SHOW THE POLITICAL WILL- TO
PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS WITH
TEACHERS WHO REFLECT THEIR
DIVERSITY AND AT THE SAME TIME
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
A- IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING AND-
TRAINING AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT PEDAGOGY. SO THAT OUR
TEACHERS WHO DON'T SHARE THE
SAME DIVERSITY OF OUR STUDENTS-
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE TRAINING-
SO THAT WE AVOID REINFORCING
STEREOTYPES AND THINGS THAT
COULD BE HARMFUL TO OUR
STUDENTS. I'M AT THIS POINT I
YIELD TO IT IF OTHER PANELISTS
HAVE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND
WILL WORK TO GET AN ANSWER TO
YOUR QUESTION IS A MEMBER
MEDINA ABOUT THE PERCENTAGE.
AND OUR TEACHING FORCE- BEFORE
THE END OF THIS YEAR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER
SUPERINTENDENT- THIS LEAVE I
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS- ABOUT THREE YEARS
AGO I THINK I SAW. THE JUST THE%
NUMBERS AROUND A FIVE PERCENT.
AT WHICH BUT IT THEN IT DROPPED
BECAUSE WE HAVE MANY THAT- AT
THE TIME RETIRED. IT'S VERY
RARE THAT ANY STUDENT WOULD
HAVE ONE NATIVE- NATIVE
EDUCATOR IN UPLAND AT ONE TIME.
A STUDENT COULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY OF HAVING TO
NATIVES TEACHERS BECAUSE IF
THEY WENT THROUGH MY ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND HAD ME AND THEN THEY
HAD GONE TO ANOTHER ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND HAD ANOTHER TEACHER
WHO IS A NATIVE- NATIVE
TEACHER. AND THEN GONE TO THE
HIGH SCHOOL AND HAD ANOTHER
NATIVE TEACHER WHO WAS MY
HUSBAND THEN THEY COULD HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE TO. BUT
THAT IS A VERY RARE CASE AND
ALL OF CALIFORNIA. I WAS JUST
ADD THAT WE WERE FORTUNATE OF
IN THE TIME THAT I WAS AT
RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRUSTEE THAT WE ARE VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE YOUR FATHER
BY MY IS A- ON THE FACULTY AND
TEACHING- NATIVE AMERICAN
HISTORY TO JUST WANT TO POINT
THAT OUT CAN I COMMENT. TO
ITEMIZE BUT WAS MY ONLY NATIVE-
EDUCATOR THROUGH THE WHOLE MY
WHOLE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE DALLAS FOR
MERRILEES. OR THE
SUPERINTENDENT. THANK YOU BOTH
FOR A PARTICIPATING AND
OFFERING TESTIMONY AND BRINGING
AWARENESS ON TO THIS MUCH
NEEDED ISSUE AS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK FORWARD I'M IN ADDRESSING
THE ISSUES OF A CALIFORNIA
CULTURE AND INDIAN EDUCATION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU- MERRY LEAVE I FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THAT'S CONNECTS WE
WANT TO BRING UP-
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
WASHINGTON STATE REPRESENTATIVE
SHARON TO MICHAEL SANTOS CHAIR
OF THE WASHINGTON STATE HOUSE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING TERMINO DONALD CHAIRMAN
RAMOS MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS AND THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. FOR THE
RECORD MY NAME IS SHARON TOMIKO
SANTOS I AM OP. PROUD TO SERVE
IN THE WASHINGTON STATE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES WHERE I
CHAIRED THE HOUSE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND I HAD SERVED IN
NOT OP PASS TO BE. UP FOR THE
LAST ELEVEN YEARS AND HAVE
SERVED MY DISTRICT AND STATE
FOR THE PAST TWENTY THREE YEARS.
I AM HONORED TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS IMPORTANT DISCUSSION ON
HOW THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CAN TAKE MEANINGFUL STEPS TO
SUPPORT. THE ACADEMIC SUCCESS
OF AMERICAN INDIAN AND NATIVE
ALASKAN STUDENTS. I'M
ESPECIALLY PROUD TO JOIN MY
DEAR FRIEND AND FORMER
COLLEAGUE JOHN MCCOY. WHO
SERVED AT PIVOTAL LEADERSHIP
ROLE IN SHAPING NATIVE AMERICAN
EDUCATION POLICY IN WASHINGTON
STATE FOR THE PAST TWO DECADES.
IT IS MY PRIVILEGE TO OFFER A
BRIEF OVERVIEW AND I WANT TO
BEGIN WITH A Y. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. IT IS A COMMON FEATURE
OF ON THE NATIVE AMERICAN
CULTURE TO ENGAGE IN
STORYTELLING SO I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN WITH ONE MYSELF. THERE
WAS A. LITTLE CHILD WHO IS
ENTERING KINDERGARTEN AND UGH
THIS STUDY THAT SHE WAS ENGAGED
IN WAS ANIMAL IDENTIFICATION
AND SO THE TASK IN FRONT OF HER
WAS TO NAME THIS ANIMAL. SO THE
CHILD THOUGHT ABOUT IT. ONLY
FOR A MOMENT AND QUICKLY
RESPONDED TO HER TEACHER. AND
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. AND WHAT SHE
SAID I'M GOING TO JUST PULL
THIS UP BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
MESS IT UP- AND HOW TO SAID.
WHAT SHE SAID WAS THIS. COOPER
CALLING EACH. AND THE TEACHER
LOOK AT THIS CHILD IN SAID ALL
RIGHT DEAR THAT'S NOT CORRECT.
THAT'S WHY DON'T YOU TRY AGAIN.
NEXT SLIDE. SO THE TRUCK WAS A
LITTLE PUZZLED BECAUSE SHE
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THE ANIMAL.
SO SHE SAID ALL DO YOU MEAN THE
OR PROC. THE TEACHER LOOKED AT
THE CHILD AGAIN SADLY AND SHOOK
HER HEAD AND SAID I'M SORRY
DEAR. WE TRY ONE MORE TIME I'M
SURE THAT YOU CAN FIND OUT WHAT
THE NAME OF THIS ANALYSTS. NEXT
SLIDE. NOW THE CHILD WAS VERY
VERY PUZZLED. AND SHE TOOK A
LONG TIME TO THINK ABOUT THIS.
AND FINALLY SHE SAID. DO YOU
MEAN KILLER WHALES. AT WHICH
POINT THE TEACHER SMILED AND
PRAISE THE CHILD PROFUSELY
ABOUT GETTING THE RIGHT ANSWER.
THAT RAISES THE QUESTION NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. HOW IS SUCCESS
MEASURED. THIS CHILD NEW THREE
DIFFERENT WAYS BY WHICH TO
IDENTIFY AND IDENTIFY THE
ANIMAL. THAT SHE WAS ASKED TO
NAME AND YET THE TEACHER ONLY
RECOGNIZED ONE. GET THAT RAISES
THE FURTHER QUESTION NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. IT WHO DECIDES WHAT IS
RIGHT. WHO GETS TO DECIDE. THE
OLD START BACK UP ONE OR PLEASE.
THERE YOU GO. THIS IS A TRUE
STORY. I LEARNED FROM SENATOR
JOHN MCCOY. BECAUSE THE CHILD
INVOLVED WITH HIS GRAN TRIED.
THE WHALE THE KILLER WHALE. THE
ORCA. AND THE NATIVE BELOVED
NAME. OUR IS AN ANIMAL THAT IS
SACRED. TO THE TULALIP TRIBE TO
WHICH SENATOR MCCORD BELONGS
AND TO WHICH THERE FOR HIS
CHILD GRANDCHILD BELONGS. THIS
COMMITTEE IS WHY THIS MEETING
IS SO IMPORTANT NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. IT IS ABOUT RESPECT.
I'VE SHARED WITH YOU ON THIS
SLIDE. OF FAVORITE QUOTE OF
MINE BY AN INDIGENOUS A WOMAN
FROM AUSTRALIA BUT I THINK IT
SPEAKS VOLUMES ABOUT WHY THIS
IS IMPORTANT NOT JUST TO ME AS
A NON NATIVE PERSON. BUT TO ALL
OF US. BECAUSE OUR LIBERATION
IS BOUND UP WITH ONE ANOTHER.
THE MORE THAT WE CAN LEARN
ABOUT OUR NEIGHBORS. OUR
CHILDREN. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. I
SHARE WITH YOU AN OVERVIEW
TIMELINE OF WASHINGTON AT THE
END OF EDUCATION POLICY OVER
THE LAST THIRTY YEARS. ARE YOU
CAN LOOK AT IT MORE DEEPLY AT
YOUR LEISURE BUT THERE ARE
THREE POINTS THAT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AS IMPORTANT
PRECEDENTS. TO HOWL WASHINGTON
STATE WAS ABLE TO ENGAGE IN
TRAVEL HISTORY AND CULTURE
LEGISLATION. FIRST AND
FOREMOST. BEGINNING IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE AND THEN REMOVED IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. THE STATE
OF WASHINGTON. ENTERED INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE SEVERAL
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN
WASHINGTON STATE. TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SOVEREIGNTY
WHICH IS INHERENT IN
INDEPENDENT FOR EACH OF THE
TRUCKS. AND THAT WE AS CO
GOVERNMENTS HAD MUTUAL
INTERESTS IN A VARIETY OF
ISSUES INCLUDING THE EDUCATION
OF INDIAN STUDENTS. SECONDLY I
WOULD HIGHLIGHT THAT WITHOUT
THE ELECTION OF NATIVE
LEGISLATE WARS WHO CHAMPIONED
THE EDUCATION OF NOT JUST THEIR
COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATURE
BUT THE PUBLIC AT LARGE. WAS
ESSENTIAL PEOPLE LIKE SENATOR
MCCORD. PEOPLE LIKE SENATOR
CLAUDIA KAUFMAN AND I CURRENTLY
SERVE WITH REPRESENTATIVE
DEBORAH LOOK KIND OF. ALL ARE
IMPORTANT TWO HELPING KEEP OUR
LEGISLATURE ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
UP PROVISIONS. AND THE
PRINCIPLES OF THE CENTENNIAL
ACCORD AND MILLENNIAL AGREEMENT
AND THEN FINALLY. WE HAD
MULTIPLE EFFORTS THAT FOCUSED
ON. WHAT ADDITIONALLY WE CALLED
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP FOR
DIFFERENT RACIAL AND ETHNIC
SUBGROUPS BUT EVENTUALLY CAME
TO RECOGNIZE THAT IT WAS
ACTUALLY AN OPPORTUNITY GAP
WHERE AS THE CHAIRMAN INDICATED
WE HAVE OVER A LACK OF
RESOURCES THAT ARE ACTUALLY
DEDICATED TO NARROWING AND
EVENTUALLY ELIMINATING THE
DIFFERENTIAL PERFORMANCE UP ON
ACADEMIC MEASURES AND TESTS FOR
DIFFERENT STUDENTS. I WILL
DISCUSS THOSE ELEMENTS A LITTLE
FURTHER IN THAT- IN THE
REMAINING PORTION OF THIS
SLIDESHOW. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
THE SUBJECT OF YOUR INTEREST AS
I UNDERSTAND IS THIS BILL.
SUBSTITUTE HOUSE BILL FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE WHICH WAS ENACTED
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
CREATING THE TRAVEL HISTORY AND
CULTURE OF. POLICY FOR THE
STATE OF WASHINGTON AND AS YOU
CAN SEE THE HIGHLIGHTED A LOT
STATEMENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
FINDS THAT THE LACK OF ACCURATE
AND COMPLETE CURRICULUM MAY
CONTRIBUTE. TO THE PERSISTENT%
ACHIEVEMENT GAP BETWEEN INDIAN
AND OTHER STUDENTS WAS THE
PRIMARY FOCUS OF THIS BILL.
HOWEVER AND I THINK THAT THERE
IS A HANDOUT FOR YOU OF THE
FULL BILL- ED. BUT IN ADDITION
TO THAT NOT ONLY WAS THEIR
FOCUS ON NATIVE STUDENTS BUT
IMPLICITLY RECOGNIZING THAT ALL
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY IN THE OUR
INCREASINGLY INTERCONNECTED
INTERNATIONAL WORLD. THAT ALL
STUDENTS BENEFIT FROM INCREASED
KNOWLEDGE. ABOUT NATIVE HISTORY
CULTURE AND LANGUAGE. THE
HEALTH EDUCATION COMMITTEE ON
WASHINGTON HAD MULTIPLE AFTER
OPPORTUNITIES TO VISIT SCHOOLS
THAT ACTUALLY ARE PRACTICED OUR
TRAVEL HISTORY AND CULTURE
WHICH LEADS TO THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THIS LEGISLATION. WHERE
NATIVE FOCUSED CURRICULUM.
IMPROVED ACADEMIC MEASURES OF
SUCCESS FOR ALL STUDENTS.
FURTHER WE FOUND THAT THE
PRACTICE BECAUSE OF THE FOCUS
ON SOVEREIGNTY IMPROVE
COMMUNITY RELATIONS AND THE
PLACES WHERE THE SCHOOLS ARE
EXISTED AS LOCAL SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENTS ADMINISTRATORS
AND ELECTED SCHOOL BOARD
DIRECTORS LEARN HOW TO ENGAGE
IN AUTHENTIC AND MEANINGFUL
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AND COORDINATING
TOGETHER A PROGRAM OF EDUCATION
FOR THEIR STUDENTS. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
BOTH AND THIS BILL FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE AS WELL AS IN THE
PRACTICE BEFORE. THE GOVERNMENT
TO GOVERNMENT RELATIONS THAT
HELPED DEVELOP THE CURRICULA.
WAS LOCALLY DRIVEN AND WE HAVE
NOT AS MANY AS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT WE HAVE TWENTY
NINE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES AND PROBABLY TEN OR
DOZEN NON RECOGNIZED TRIBES
EACH UP WITH ITS OWN CULTURE.
ITS OWN HISTORY AND AGAIN ON
FOREVER THE RECOGNIZED TRIBES
THE ISSUE OF SOVEREIGNTY WHICH
IS INHERENT AND INDEPENDENT AND
LEARNING TO WORK TOGETHER WAS
AN IMPORTANT LESSON NOT ONLY
FOR THE ADULTS IN THE SYSTEM.
BUT ALSO FOR MODELING FOR THE
STUDENTS IN THE SYSTEM. HOUSE
BILL FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE THEN
ALLOWED FOR THE STATE I BEG
YOUR PARDON I AM HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH MY MOUTH- AT
ALLOWED FOR THE STATE. TO
ENGAGE IN DEVELOPING THROUGH
OUR OFFICE OF NATIVE EDUCATION
IN THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT'S
OFFICE ON DEVELOPING A
STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK BECAUSE
WHILE THESE EXAMPLES OF OUR
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS LEADING TO GOOD LOCAL
MADE OF HISTORY AND CULTURE
CURRICULUM. WERE I SHINING
SPOTS THE WORD JUST THAT JUST
SPOTS AND WE WANTED TO SEE THIS.
OUR EXPANDED ALL ACROSS THE
STATE SO THE FRAMEWORK PROVIDED
BY SINCE TIME IMMEMORIAL. HAS A
BASIC FRAMEWORK WHICH THEN
LOCAL DISTRICTS CAN ADAPT TO IN
IN COORDINATION WITH THE LOCAL
TRIBES. OUGHT TO MEET THEN THE
LOCAL CONDITIONS THE LOCAL
HISTORY THE LOCAL CULTURE
BECAUSE LIKE CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
A COASTAL PORTION OF OUR STATE
BUT WE HAVE AN INTERIOR PORTION
OF OUR STATE AND THE CULTURES
ARE VERY VERY DIFFERENT. AT THE
SAME TIME I MENTIONED THAT- WE
HAVE HAD MULTIPLE WE HAD OTHER
EFFORTS TO ELIMINATE THE
ACHIEVEMENT OF LOS LASH
OPPORTUNITY GAPS FOR MULTIPLE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC GROUPS. FOR
THE NATURE OF OUR COMMUNITY- WE
HAD COMMISSIONED. A REPORT. TO
ASK THE FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES IN THE STUDENTS OF
NATIVE AMERICAN AMERICAN INDIAN
NATIVE ALASKAN HERITAGE. WHAT
THEY WANTED FROM SCHOOL WHAT
THEY EXPECTED OF THEIR SUDENTS
AND THAT DOCUMENT THREE HUNDRED
PAGE DOCUMENT OF WAS ISSUED IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT ENTITLED
FROM WHERE THE SUN RISES. THAT
HELPS CREATE THE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY GAP OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE
LEADING TO POLICIES THAT
INCLUDED DISAGGREGATED DATA.
ULTRA COMPETENCY STANDARDS AND
TRAINING INCREASING THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR ETHNIC
TEACHERS. REFORMING DISCIPLINE
AND FACILITATING FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT OR
ENGAGEMENT NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
SADLY OUR EFFORTS WERE STILL
SPORADIC BECAUSE SHE IN THE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE- BILL WAS TRYING
TO RESPECT LOCAL CONTROL OF OUR
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND SO
THE WORD WAS TO ENCOURAGE.
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS. TEN
YEARS LATER AS YOU CAN SEE ON
THE SLIDE THE LEGISLATURE
FELLOW THAT MERELY ENCOURAGING
EDUCATION REGARDING
WASHINGTON'S TRIBAL HISTORY AND
CULTURE AND GOVERNMENT WAS NOT
SUFFICIENT AND THEREFORE THE
LEGISLATURE DECLARED ITS INTENT
THAT SUCH EDUCATION BE
MANDATORY IN WASHINGTON COMMON
SCHOOLS. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT TWO THINGS OCCURRED.
IN THE PASSAGE OF THIS BILL ONE
BY THEN WE HAD THE STI
CURRICULUM DEVELOPED AND SHARED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. BUT TO. I
FOR INSIDER POLITICS IN
WASHINGTON I WOULD NOTE THAT
THE PRIME SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION. I IS A IS THE
REPUBLIC REPUBLICAN CHAIR OF
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
AT THE TIME. WELL SENATOR MCCOY
OBVIOUSLY CONTINUE TO GUIDE THE
DEVELOPMENT THE POINT IS WE
RECOGNIZED IN THE WASHINGTON
STATE LEGISLATURE THAT THE
SUCCESS OF OUR STUDENTS IS A BI
PARTISAN MANNER. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. I DO WANT TO STAND FOR
YOUR QUESTION FOR THE LAST TWO
SLIDES ARE REALLY- THIS ONE
TALKS ABOUT OTHER EDUCATION
NATIVE EDUCATION INITIATIVES
THAT TOOK PLACE DURING THIS
TIME THAT YOU MIGHT FIND OF
INTEREST UP AGAIN SENATOR MCCOY
HELPED SHEPHERD THE STATE
TRIBAL EDUCATION COMPAQ SCHOOLS
WHEREBY. ARE RELYING ON THE
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON AND A TRIED CAN
ENTER INTO A CONTRACT AGREEMENT
WHERE THE TRIED PROVIDES THE
BASIC EDUCATION IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE STATE'S UP
REQUIREMENTS AND MANDATES AND
THEREFORE RECEIVES FUNDING FROM
THE STATE FOR THAT CHILD'S
EDUCATION THIS IS A VOLUNTARY-
CONTACT WE HAVE DEVELOPED RACE
ETHNICITY GUIDES FOR THE DATA
DISAGGREGATION WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT AS YOU ALL KNOW
BECAUSE NOT ALL TRIBES. I HAVE
THE SAME CULTURE AND SO WE WANT
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO HELP IDENTIFIED
THEMSELVES FINALLY I THINK
GERMINAL DONAL HAD TALKED
ABOUT- TRAINING SO IN ADDITION
TO THE TRAINING THAT WE PROVIDE
TO OUR TEACHERS ARE IN THE FORM
OF PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
IN THEIR TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS. THIS YEAR WE ACTUALLY
MADE A REQUIREMENT FOR TEACHERS
AS WELL AS ADMINISTRATORS-
OUGHT TO RECEIVE A MANDATORY A
PERCENTAGES OF THEIR TRAINING
TEACHERS I THINK IT'S 15% OF
THEIR RECERTIFICATION HOURS
MUST BE DEVOTED TO. LEARNING
ABOUT MULTI CULTURAL HISTORY.
AND CULTURE. FOR A MINUTE
THERE'S A PARTICULAR ADDITION
OF 5% OF THEIR CERTIFICATION
HOURS MUST BE DEVOTED
SPECIFICALLY TO DEVELOPING
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONSHIP. AND THAT THAT
CURRICULA IS ACTUALLY APPROVED
BY THE TRIBES AND PROVIDED BY
THE TRIBES. FINALLY AND THIS
IS- A NOTE TO A REP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA WE- WE STAND
NATIVE NAMES AND SYMBOLS AND
IMAGES FROM SCHOOLS FROM SCHOOL
TEAMS- JUST THIS YEAR AND SOME
OF THE MOST MOVING TESTIMONY
THAT I HAVE HEARD IN MY
COMMUNITY. CAME DIRECTLY FROM
THE STUDENTS WHO TALKED ABOUT
THE TRAUMA OF HEARING. AND
SEEING IMAGES AND HEARING NAMES
THAT WERE INTENDED TO BE
DISPARAGING AND DISRESPECTFUL.
IN THE FUTURE WE DO HOPE TO
CONTINUE OUR WORK BOTH IN
OFFERING INTO THE EARLY
LEARNING. ARENA OF FOR STI
TRADING FOR LIFTING UP DUAL
LANGUAGE TRAINING FOR OUR-
NATIVE STUDENTS TO NOT FORGET
THEIR NATIVE TONGUES. AND
FINALLY TO- HOPEFULLY CREATE A
SEPARATE BODY WHEREBY AN ACCORD
OR AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN OUR
GOVERNMENTS CAN EXIST BETWEEN
THE LEGISLATURE OF WASHINGTON.
AND THE SEPARATE TRIBES BECAUSE
CURRENTLY THE CENTENNIAL
ACCORDING MILLENNIAL AGREEMENT
ONLY- AFFECT THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. I
WILL END UP BY SAYING OUR
EFFORTS IN WASHINGTON STATE
HAVE ALL FOCUSED ON. WHAT OUR
MOTTO ON THE HOUSE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WHICH IS TO BE
STUDENT CENTERED AND SUCCESSFUL
COST WHERE WE FIND STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT IS ESSENTIAL. TO
SUCCESS. AND THAT THAT
ENGAGEMENT NEED MUST BE BASED
ON MEANINGFUL RELEVANT
CURRICULUM AND TRUTH
TRANSFERABLE KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILLS. I DO OFFER THIS ARE
CLOSING- AS I SAY I APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE
OVERVIEW OF WASHINGTON STATE'S
EXPERIENCE I WISH TO STAY GREAT
SEED. THANK YOU- YOU YOU HAVE
COOPER I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT ARTIST ONLY WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE STATE OF WASHINGTON
HAS EVOLVED FROM THE WHERE THE
FIRST PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND
NOW TO WHERE YOU'RE AT AT THIS
TIME WE LIKE TO CALL ON SENATOR
MCCOY- WE'VE ASKED THE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ALLOW HIM ACCESS I UNDERSTAND
HE'S GOING TO BE OFFERING
TESTIMONY. THROUGH OUR PHONE
LINES. SENATE DEMOCRATS YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING- A REPRESENTATIVE
SAMPLE EXCELLENT JOB ON THE LAW.
THE HISTORY OF- HOUSE BILL.
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE- THIS THIS
LEGISLATION. OUR BEGAN THEY ARE
RIVALED STATE MEANING I WAS
BEING HELD ON THE CLAN ALL
NUMEROUS PATIENTS. WE CAN NOT
TO THOUSAND THREE. AND- SO
THAT'S WHERE- THAT WAS MY FIRST
YEAR. I IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
SO I WAS OUT THERE TO BE A FLY
ON THE WALL. AND OUR EVENTUALLY
WELL THE QUESTION WAS THAT WHAT
WHAT IS IT IS THE TRIBES WANT.
AND- A TRAVEL LEADERS STOOD UP
AND SAID WE WANT OUR TRIBAL
HISTORY AND CULTURE TAUGHT. IN
THE SCHOOLS. SO THAT BEGAN THE
PROCESS- WHICH CREATED HOUSE
BILL FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE. THEN
AND THEN THE SUBSEQUENT
VEHICLES- GOOD GOOD STORY-
THAT- THE PRESENT OF SOME SALT
THOSE- SPOKE ABOUT MY GRANDSON
GOING THROUGH. MORE OF SECOND
GRADE WITH THE U. H. THAT
THEY'RE REALLY UPSET ME AND NOW
WHEN HE CAME ALL. AND TOLD ME
ABOUT IT NATURALLY I WENT DOWN
TO THE SCHOOL AND MOM LET THEM
KNOW ABOUT MY DISPLEASURE. SO-
SO. THERE'S JUST SHOWS. HOW
QUARTERLY- HISTORY HAS BEEN
TALKED ABOUT TRUMP GROUPS. SO
THE BILL WILL GET THE BALL-
THERE'S A LOT OF TRIBAL
INVOLVEMENT- IT'S THE TRIBES.
WHO- THEIR HISTORY. CLICK TRIED
TO HOLD LANGUAGE. SELBYVILLE
THE INDIVIDUAL THAT- ARE THE
KEEPERS- OF THEIR HISTORY AND
LANGUAGE AND SO- WE ALSO DID
ANOTHER BELL. THAT- BASICALLY
SAYS THAT- IT'S TO TRY. THAT
CERTIFIED SOMEONE IN OUR
LANGUAGE. AND NOT A- ALL RIGHT
ALSO IN ART HISTORY- S. T. E.
R. IT'S A VERY- GOOD DOCUMENT
AND- WHAT IT PROVIDE IS BASIC
INFORMATION ABOUT ALL CHARGE.
SO WHEN YOU GET IN THE CIRCUIT
COURT OF THE CREATION OF THE
TRIED- IN THEIR LANGUAGE- THAT
COMES FROM THE CHART- SO. HAVE
THAT SUPPORT NETWORK COMPANIES
STRONG. SO- WE ARE- WASHINGTON
SAY THAT SLOWLY BUILDING- IT A
CLOUD NATIVE AMERICAN- CAGING
GROUP. AND- SO IF THAT IS
GROWING- WE HAVE- OKAY- HELLO
TRY TO REMEMBER- SHE- IN THE
TEACHING OF- PRINCE. AND THEN-
SHE DOES THAT WORK AND THEN HER
HUSBAND. IS THAT YOU'VE GOTTEN
UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON. AGING
SUPERINTENDENT. THEN THIS IS
IMPORTANT AND YOU YOU NEED TO
WORK WITH YOUR COLLEGES OF
EDUCATION. TO ENSURE THE FOLKS
THAT THE- COMIC TEACHERS. THEY
GET THE EDUCATION ALSO. THEN
THAT DAY BE ABLE TO TEACHER IN
A MANNER THAT'S RESPECTFUL. TO
THE TRIBAL NATIONS. VERY
IMPORTANT- HELLO YOU YOU MAY
HAVE LEGISLATION HERE YOU DID
AT THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM YOU
ALSO NEED LEGISLATION COULD.
COLLEGES OF EDUCATION- SO- ALL
THAT TOOK A LOT OF WORK ON.
AND- IT'S GROWN AND- AGAIN- THE
REPRESENTED SANTIAGO GOOD GOOD
A LOT OF THE HISTORY- ON THE
LEGISLATION. AND SO I I'M AT A
POINT WHERE WE JUST NEED TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND YOUR
WORK- NOT ONLY IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON BUT THROUGHOUT THE
WHOLE NATION AND LEADING- THE
INDIAN PEOPLE THE NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
NATION ARE MOVING FORWARD A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION- AND ALSO-
RECOGNIZING CINEMA BECAUSE I AS
A MEMBER OF THE- TO ALLOW THE
TRIBE IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON- SO MUCH HAS BEEN
DONE. ON TO- ENGAGE IN THE
LEGISLATURE THEIR WASHINGTON
FROM EARLY BEGINNINGS OF SEEING
WHAT WHAT IS GOING ON WITH HIS
GRANDSON SCHOOLS THAT PROMPTED
THAT THAT THAT PASSION TO SEE A
CHANGE MOVE FORWARD I THINK-
REPRESENTATIVE US ON THOSE FOR
SHARING A TESTIMONY OF WHERE
THE STATE OF WASHINGTON HAS
COME FROM- FROM THE FIRST.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL TO
WHERE YOU'RE AT NOW AND I WOULD
ONLY HOPE THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO START WHERE WHERE WHERE
WHERE YOU STARTED OFF AT AN
ULTIMATELY GET TO WHERE WE NEED
TO BE. ARMED WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO OPEN UP THE
DICE MANY QUESTIONS FOR
REPRESENTATIVE SIMON SENATOR
MCCOY. FROM THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON. THANK YOU TEREMOS
UM MAYBE. JUST A CO. YEAH I
WERE TO THANK REPRESENTATIVES.
FOR BEING WITH US AND I DO
THINK THAT THE STORY THAT YOU
SHARED AT THE BEGINNING IS SO
POWERFUL BECAUSE IT'S SHOWS THE
DIFFERENCE- OF. THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM. OF WHAT THEY CAN AND-
CAN DO. AND HOW THEY APPROACH
STUDENTS WHETHER THEY SEE THE
CULTURE THAT STUDENTS BRING
WITH THEM. AS A PLUS. OR THE
MINUS. AND TOO OFTEN IT'S BEEN
THE LATER- AND- STUDENTS I
THINK OF ALL CULTURES BRING
SUCH RICH EXPERIENCE WITH THEM.
AND DID THE JOB OF EDUCATORS IS
TO VALIDATE THAT EXPERIENCE.
AND NOT TO DO THE OPPOSITE
WHICH IS TO DISCARDED- THE
HISTORY I THINK OF NATIVE
AMERICANS AND WITH BOARDING
SCHOOLS WHERE THEY STE
STRIPPED. STUDENTS OF THEIR
CULTURE- IS THAT LONG HISTORY
AND- I THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE THIS MORNING TO
HELP AS. DO MUCH BETTER HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO I
JUST HAVE A YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ANY OF ANY OTHER
ANYBODY ALSO DIVES GERMAN. JUST
JUST A FOLLOW UP- QUESTION AS
FAR AS I MIGHT IDENTIFIED- AND
TALKING- WHAT THE- CHAIRMAN
DONALD ALLUDE TO AS FAR AS
RESOURCES BEING AVAILABLE RIGHT
RESOURCES THAT HOPEFULLY ARE
APPROVED BY THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY THAT ULTIMATELY.
TEACHERS ARE ABLE TO USE
BECAUSE WE HEARD- AND IN
TESTIMONY EARLIER THAT AT ONE
POINT THERE WAS A HIGH A 5%
NATIVE AMERICAN TEACHERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT WE
KNOW THAT A LOT OF THIS WOULD
BE ON TOP BY NON NATIVE
TEACHERS BUT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE CURRICULUM IS ONE THING IN
THE IN THE CHAIRMAN SO ELOQUENT
BRINGING UP THE RESOURCES
NEEDED FOR THE CLASSROOM. HOW
DID THE STATE OF WASHINGTON
DEAL WITH THAT COMPONENT-
CONTINUE TO MOVE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION FORWARD TO FURTHER-
AWARENESS OF THE NATIVE.
AMERICAN PEOPLE THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON. WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISS CHAIRMAN FOR THAT.
AND I DON'T. WANT TO SOUND AS
IF I AM- BEING MAKING LIGHT OF
THE QUESTION BUT OF COURSE
EVERY STATE KNOWS. THERE'S
NEVER GONNA BE ENOUGH MONEY. TO
DO. THE BEST THAT WE PLANT THEM
UP AND YET AT THE SAME TIME WE
DO HAVE A WEALTH OF RESOURCES
THAT ARE AT OUR DISPOSAL AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK SO. IT WAS
SO IMPORTANT FOR THE BEDROCK OF
HOSTILE FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE
THE FOCUS ON THE GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS BECAUSE A
LOT OF THE RICH CONTENT HISTORY.
OF A AND KNOWLEDGE IS ACTUALLY
AS SENATOR MORE QUARRY ALREADY
INDICATED. IN THE- THAT. IT'S
IN THE HANDS ARE AND THE
PROTECTION OF OUR TRIBES. AND
SO IT'S VITALLY IMPORTANT FOR
WE AS NOT ONLY A STATE
REPRESENTATIVE OR STATE
OFFICIAL BUT ALSO FOR US TO
ENCOURAGE OUR OTHER LOCALLY
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO LEARN HOW
TO ENGAGE IN THE GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONSHIP IN AN
AUTHENTIC AND RESPECTFUL
FASHION. I WILL SAY ALL OF THE
OTHER THING THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO DO. IS AND THIS IS NOT TO
GET INTO TOO MUCH DETAIL BUT IN
A VARIETY OF PLACES WHETHER IT
WAS UNDER THE OLD NCLB
FRAMEWORK OR UNDER THE NAME S.
A FRAMEWORK. WE WERE ABLE TO
BUILD IN- BOTH REQUIREMENTS
AROUND- PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING FOR
CULTURAL COMPETENCY WE WERE
ABLE TO- BUILD IN
ACCOUNTABILITY THROUGH THE-
FOUR TIERED SYSTEM. OF
EVALUATION OF WE WERE SO IT WAS
A- IT WAS A MANUAL OF BOTH-
CARROTS AND- STICKS I SUPPOSE
OUGHT TO HELP. OF THAT ALREADY
EXISTED IN OUR SYSTEM WHERE WE
JUST ADDED TO IT ON AND USE
WHAT WAS ALREADY AVAILABLE TO
US. ON INCLUDING AGAIN THE
RESOURCES THE RICH RESOURCES OF
OUR TRIBAL KNOWLEDGE. THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND SENATE MCGUIRE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD TO THAT.
THOSE COMMENTS. YEAH IN THE
BEGINNING OF UNDER. FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE- THAT'S WHY WE PUT
SUCH AN EMPHASIS. ON- THE
TEACHERS AND THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THE TRIBES GETTING
TOGETHER AND WORKING TOGETHER-
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF ANY
CURRICULUM- AGAIN IT'S YOU
TRIED THAT THAT- HAS YOUR
CREATION STORY AND THAT'S WHAT
IS BEING TAUGHT. SO- THERE THE
HOLDERS OF THAT STORY. SO THEY
NEED TO WORK WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE DELIVERY. AND
NOW IT'S THE LEOPARD- THAT'S
WHY YOU NEED TO WORK WITH THE
COLLEGES OF EDUCATION. TO H.
THEM ON HOW TO DEVELOPER THE
STORAGE- BECAUSE- ALL TRIBES-
OUR STORYTELLER AND. SO THE
TEACHERS CREATURE THAT WAY SO
THAT THE STUDENTS ALL
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS IS BEING
DONE. AND NOW IT GETS CLEANED
OUT OF. IF THE STORY CORRECT. I
WANT TO THANK- THE PRESENTERS
ON THIS PANEL- THAT BROUGHT TO
LIGHT- AGAIN HISTORIC
INFORMATION TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND- TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- MERRY LEAVE I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AS WELL AS
REPRESENTATIVE OF SANTOS IN
SENATOR MCCOY FOR BRINGING TO
LIGHT THE ISSUES AND
TROUBLESHOOTING THROUGH SOME OF
THE BILLS AND IMPLEMENTING ALL
THESE PIECES OF LEGISLATION.
AND I THINK- CHAU DONNA FOR
ALLOWING US TO MOVE THAT PANEL
FLOWED IN THAT DISCUSSION IS A
TURN OVER TO CHANNEL NOW. THANK
THANK YOU MISTER ROBERTS AND I
JUST DID A QUICK SEARCH HELLO
BY THE SAN GABRIEL RIVER RATHER
WHAT IF I WANTED TO TEACH ABOUT
THE HISTORY OF THIS ANNUAL
RIVER IS ACTUALLY NOT MUCH ON
THERE ARE A LOT OF IT IS POSTED
SPANISH ARRIVAL- SON AND NOT
REALLY MUCH I COULD USE IN A
CLASSROOM SETTING SO THAT'S
KIND OF THE PERSPECTIVE I BRING
IS YOU I'M A TEACHER. I WANNA I
WANNA I WANNA TEACH THIS ANA
YEAH SURE KIDS IT'S NOT A FLOOD.
CHANNEL ACTUALLY RIVER- AND
THAT IS THE KIND THINGS THAT.
THAT THAT I TALKING ABOUT THAT
BUT THEN I NEED. AS A CLASSROOM.
TO AFFORD THIS MAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THEY YOU. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO A PANEL NUMBER
THREE. AGAIN PANEL NUMBER THREE
WILL FIRST HEAR FROM CENTER
WEBER INDIAN EDUCATION
SPECIALIST. WITH THE SAMBAR
DINO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IT WAS JOINING US IN
PERSON I BELIEVE. THERE SHE IS.
COME FORWARD WHEN YOU PERCEIVE
AND READY. MISS WEBER. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN ROSS AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY. MY
NAME IS SAM COULD YOU DO ME A
FAVOR JUST COULD YOU MOVE THAT
MICROPHONE A LITTLE BIT CLOSER
SUIT. HELLO AS FAR AS HEARING
YOUR VOICE THANK YOU. OKAY MY
NAME IS SANDRA WEBER. I AM A
DESCENDANT OF THE LAKOTA NATION
MY LOOK UP THE NAME. I HAVE
WORKED FOR THE SAMBAR TO DINO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
TITLE SIX INDIAN EDUCATION
PROGRAM. FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
AND HAVE BEEN INVOLVED WITH THE
PROGRAM SINCE ITS CONCEPTION IN
THE LATE NINETEEN EIGHTIES. THE
PROGRAM HAS ITS ORIGINS IN THE
WORK OF TRIBAL ELDERS FROM THE
SAN MANUEL BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS WHO FOR DECADES WENT TO
LOCAL SCHOOLS TO SHARE THEIR
SERRANO CULTURE WITH LOCAL AREA
STUDENTS WHILE EXPLORING GRANT
PATHWAYS. TO CONTINUE THESE
PROGRAMS. THERE AT. THERE
ADVOCACY AND PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR EDUCATORS HELPED ESTABLISH
A GRANT FOR INDIAN EDUCATION IN
THE DISTRICT WHICH IS STILL
BEING USED TODAY. THE TITLE SIX
PROGRAM MAKE SURE THAT ALL
FOURTH GRADE TEACHERS HAVE THE
CURRICULUM TO TEACH THE TRUTH.
ABOUT CALIFORNIA INDIAN HISTORY.
INCLUDING A RESOURCE BOOK ABOUT
THE SAN MANUEL TRIBE CALLED
PEOPLE OF THE PINES WITH
ACCOMPANYING LESSON PLAN THAT
MEETS DISTRICT AND STATE
STANDARDS. FOR THE PAST TWENTY
TWO YEARS THE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
TITLE SIX INDIAN EDUCATION
PROGRAM HAS PARTNERED WITH
SALMON WELL TO BRING STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS ON FIELD TRIPS AND
WORKSHOPS. FOR THE WEEK LONG
CALIFORNIA INDIAN CULTURAL
AWARENESS PROGRAM HELD IN HONOR
OF OUR STATE'S NATIVE AMERICAN
DAY. I COORDINATE WORKSHOPS
THAT BRING TEACHERS IN FROM ALL
OVER OUR DISTRICT AND DO FOLLOW
UP WORK AT THEIR SCHOOL SITES
WITH THE INFORMATION LEARNED
FROM THE TRIBALLY LED
WORKSHOPS. AND FIELD TRIPS FOR
STUDENTS. ADDITIONALLY TO
PERSONIFY THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
EXPERIENCE I EMPLOY THE BOOK.
LAND OF OUR ANCESTORS BY GARY
ROBINSON WHICH IS GIVEN TO
EVERY ELEMENTARY SCHOOL LIBRARY
AND CLASSROOM IF REQUESTED.
THIS BOOK PROVIDES AN
ALTERNATIVE FOR THE TYPICAL
TEACHING ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
MISSION PERIOD. MISTER
ROBINSON'S BOOK WRITTEN FROM A
SHOE MATCH CHILD'S PERSPECTIVE
SHOWING THE REALISTIC PAIN AND
SUFFERING OF CALIFORNIA INDIANS
DURING A BRUTAL PERIOD IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY. AND I HAVE
BROUGHT YOU ALL A COPY OF THE
PUT. IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING A
MORE ACCURATE TALLY OF THE
MISSION ERROR IN CALIFORNIA OUR
CURRICULUM ALSO PROVIDE
STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE THE MANY NAMES OF
CITIES STATES MOUNTAINS. AND
OTHER SIGNIFICANT LANDSCAPES
THAT ORIGINATE FROM CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PEOPLES AND THEIR
LANGUAGES. THE CREATION OF
CURRICULUM THAT HIGHLIGHTS THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE EXPERIENCE
BOTH IN THE PAST AS WELL AS THE
PRESIDENT. IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE OF THE UNDERSTANDING
APPRECIATION FOR DIVERSITY AND
EMPATHY THAT IT CREATES LET ME
SHARE WITH YOU AND IT- INCIDENT.
THAT ILLUSTRATES THIS POINT. I
HAVE A STUDENT WHO WHEN HE WAS
IN SECOND GRADE. WAS BEING
BULLIED VERBALLY AND PHYSICALLY
ABOUT HIS LONG HAIR. AND FOR
HAVING A DIFFERENT NAME. WHEN
THE PLAYGROUND WRECKAGE WOULD
NOT DO ANYTHING ABOUT HIS
COMPLAINTS HIS MOTHER AND I
WORKED WITH A FOURTH GRADE
TEACHER TO HAVE BEEN GO TO HER
CLASS IF YOU IS HAVING ANY.
PROBLEMS HE WAS NOT DOING WELL
ACADEMICALLY. DUE TO THE
BULLYING AND HE DID NOT FEEL A
SENSE OF BELONGING TO HIS
SCHOOL. TODAY AT THAT YOUNG
WARRIOR. ACHILLES WAR CRY HEART
THE WALLACE. IS IN ITS FIRST
YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL LAST YEAR
TO EIGHTH GRADE HE FINISHED
NUMBER ONE. OF IN HIS CASS BY
SHARING HIS NATIVE CULTURE WITH
HIS CLASSMATES THEY WERE ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF CERTAIN THINGS THAT THEY MAY
NOT EXPERIENCE IN THEIR OWN
LIVES. BUT OUR IMPORTANCE TO
OTHER COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT EXPERIENCE
HE HAS BLOOD STEM ACADEMICALLY
AND SOCIALLY. HAVING CALIFORNIA
INDIAN HISTORY IN OUR
CURRICULUM IS NEEDED NOT ONLY
FOR OUR NATIVE STUDENTS TO FEEL
SEEN HEARD AND VALUED BUT FOR
ALL STUDENTS TO BENEFIT FROM
LEARNING ABOUT NATIVE
TRADITIONS AND CULTURE. WE HAVE
SEEN THAT WHEN WE INCLUDE IN
DEPTH AND HISTORICALLY ACCURATE
NATIVE AMERICAN CURRICULUM ARE
NATIVE STUDENTS ARE AFFIRMED.
THE IMPACT IS SIGNIFICANT AND
REAL. TO FURTHER EXPLAIN SALMON
TO DO YOU KNOW CITY IS A
DISADVANTAGED SOCIO ECONOMIC
AREA THE SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
APPROXIMATELY. FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE STUDENTS. I WORK
WITH APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
SELF IDENTIFIED NATIVE STUDENTS
IN GRADES K. THROUGH TWELVE.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
DASHBOARD LAST YEAR OUR
DISTRICTS NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS HAD CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM DROPPED BY FOUR
POINT 3% AND THEIR SUSPENSION
RATE DECLINED BY 4% IN THE.
NINETEEN TWENTY ACADEMIC YEAR
BURKE IN INDIA AND-
GROWGENERATION RIGHT WAS 95%
THE HIGHEST IN CALIFORNIA
UTTARAPATHA RESERVATIONS AND
THAT IS SOMETHING I AM VERY
PROUD OF. IN CLOSING I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF OUR
INDIGENOUS STUDENTS AND
RECOGNIZE THE SAN MANUEL BAND
OF MISSION AREA. FOR THEIR
REMARKABLE COMMITMENT AND
PARTNERSHIP IN MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IN OUR STUDENTS
EDUCATION AND LIVES. WE KNOW
THERE INVESTMENT IN EDUCATING
THE CITIZENS OF OUR REGION. IS
CHANGING THE COURSE OF HISTORY
FOR MANY FAMILIES. AS WELL AS
OUR STATE AND NATION. AND THANK
YOU FOR THE HONOR. OF SPEAKING
BEFORE YOU TODAY. THANK YOU
MISS WEBER MAYBE YOU COULD STAY
THERE JUST BECAUSE WE MIGHT ASK
QUESTIONS I DON'T LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE BY WEBEX
SERIOUSLY THAT WOULD BE GREAT-
WILL NEXT GO TO MARKET ROBBINS
INDIAN EDUCATION A NATIVE
LANGUAGE DIRECTOR WITH THE
KLAMATH TRINITY JOINT UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT ADDED AND-
MARGARET IS JOINING US BY WEBEX.
I AGREE NEXT NOW MARGO ROBBINS
CICEK INDIAN EDUCATION AND
NATIVE LANGUAGE DIRECTORFOR
KLAMATH TRINITY JOINT UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. LOCATED IN
FARMERS CALIFORNIA ON THE
ANCESTRAL TERRITORIES. OF THE
WHOLE BAR YUROK KARUK AND THAT
WAY. WE HAVE TO HIGH SCHOOLS
AND FIVE ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS IN
OUR DISTRICT RANGING IN SIZE
FROM TWELVE STUDENTS TO FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY STUDENT.
ENROLLMENT IS APPROXIMATELY ONE
THOUSAND TWELVE STUDENTS. 87%
OF THEM ARE NATIVE AMERICAN.
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF THE
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WE SERVE
THE INDIAN EDUCATION PROGRAM
DEVELOPED KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
TWELFTH GRADE CURRICULUM BASED
ON THE HISTORY AND CULTURE OF
THE LOCAL TRIBES IT IS CALLED
THE WHO BARBARA CUDDLED. IN THE
INLAND TENURE CURRICULUM IT IS
ALLOWING TO ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ARTS CALIFORNIA COMMON CORE
STANDARDS IT MEET SOCIAL
STUDIES AND SCIENCE STANDARD AS
WELL BUT WE CHOSE TO LIST ONLY
E. LA STANDARDS HOW'S THIS
SUBJECT THAT IS REQUIRED. TO BE
FOUGHT EVERY DAY. WHEN WE FIRST
ABOUT THE COR. OUR DISTRICT
YELLING AT OPTIONS WHO AND MAKE
WITH THEM SO WE APPLIED THE
INDIAN LAND TENURE CURRICULUM
WITH THE WHOLE IN MIDLAND SPOKE
SEQUENCE. WE CREATED AND
IMPLEMENTATION CALENDAR WHEREIN.
TENDER CURRICULUM TALK ON
FRIDAY. A DAY REVIEW IN THE
MORE TECH. ARE TEACHERS THE
SAME SCALE. NEWS THIS CALL
RELEVANT CONTENT. KATIE J. UST
OF TRUSTEES ADOPTED THE INDIAN
LAND CABLE CURRICULUM AND
TEACHERS. ARE REQUIRED TO TEACH
IT. THE CARD COVERS THREE TIMES.
ONE TIME WHEN THE PRE HUMAN
RACE OF BEINGS LIVED HERE
PREPARING THE WORLD FOR THE
PEOPLE. TO PRE CONTACT TIMES
TIME WHEN ONLY NATIVE AMERICANS
LIVED HERE AND THREE POST
CONTACT TIMES NON NATIVES
ARRIVED IN STATE. CONTENT
INCLUDES LESSONS ON TRADITIONAL
LAND VALUES LAND TENURE HISTORY
CONTEMPORARY LAND ISSUES AND
BUILDING A POSITIVE.
COMMUNITIES STUDENTS LEARN
ABOUT THEIR HOMELAND'S
TRADITIONAL PUNE WATER SEVEN
FIVE TWO ESTABLISHMENT OF
RESERVATIONS THE DOGS ACT AND
CURRENT ISSUES SUCH AS WATER
PROTECTION AND THE USE OF FIRE
AS A LAB MANAGEMENT TOOL. THE
LESSONS ARE INTERACTIVE IN A
DRESS MOTAL MULTIPLE
BRUTALITIES OF LEARNING. IT
WOULDN'T GO ON FIELD TRIPS TO
TRADITIONAL VILLAGE SITE AND
CEREMONIAL DANCES WE TAKE BOX
LOADS OF THEM TOGETHER ACORNS
ARMS FULL OF STUDENTS GET TO
SEE CULTURAL BURNS WHILE OTHERS
ON WALKS TRIPS TO IDENTIFY
TREES AND PLANTS IN THEIR
NATURAL HABITAT. WE TRY TO
INSTILL IN THEM A STRONG SENSE
OF PLACE AND PRIDE IN WHO THEY
ARE AND WHERE THEY COME FROM.
EIGHT OF LANGUAGES TAUGHT IN
ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS. THE HIGH
SCHOOL CLASSES ARE ACCEPTED AS
NEEDING THE WHOLE LANGUAGE
REQUIREMENT FOR UC AND CSU
ENTRY. WE ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO
TAKE AN ACTIVE PART IN
PROTECTING THE NATURAL
RESOURCES OF THE HOMELANDS OUR
WATER PROTECTORS CLUB WAS
CREATED AT COOPER HIGH SCHOOL
AFTER STUDENTS LEARNED ABOUT
POTENTIAL NEW WATER DIVERSIONS
FROM THE TRINITY RIVER.
STUDENTS FELT THE NEED TO
EDUCATE OTHERS ABOUT THE
THREATS TO THE TRINITY AND
KLAMATH RIVERS AND SET ABOUT
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTING A
COMMUNITY DINNER TO LET PEOPLE
KNOW WHAT WHAT'S AT RISK. THEY
TRAVELED TO STATE WATER BOARD
HEARINGS TO EDUCATE DECISION
MAKERS ABOUT HOW WATER
DIVERSION WOULD DESTROY THE
RIVER AND SEVEN WHICH NATIVE
PEOPLE CAN GET DONE. THIS IS
NOT THE FIRST STOOD GOT. TO
PRINT THEIR HOMELAND. THEY ALSO
DID AN EDUCATION. CAMPAIGN ON
STOPPING THE LIQUID NATURAL GAS
L. A. N. G. PIPELINE PROPOSED
TO GO UNDER THE KLAMATH RIVER.
THEY TRAVELED TO NUMEROUS
SCHOOLS TO CONNECT WITH OTHER
STUDENTS TO GARNER SUPPORT AND
GAVE TESTIMONY AT FEDERAL
ENERGY REGULATORY COMMISSION
REGULATORY COMMISSION HEARINGS.
THE K<c.cyan> J. UST INDIAN</c>
EDUCATION PROGRAM PROVIDED
CHAPERONES TRANSPORTATION AND
MEALS FOR THESE TRIPS TO ENABLE
STUDENTS TO EDUCATE OTHERS BY
SHARING THEIR PERSPECTIVES.
SPEAKING TRUTH. WE STRIVE TO
RECOGNIZE AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO
BE LEADERS TO STRENGTHEN AND
SHOWCASE THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILLS STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTERS ON EDUCATIONAL
WEBINARS TEACHING MOTHERS ABOUT
THE BENEFITS OF CULTURAL
BURNING AND HOW DO BIRDS SAFELY
IN TWO DAYS CHANGE LANDSCAPES
WE ARE FUTURE GOOD CHILDREN'S
BOOKS CREATED BY THE INDIAN
EDUCATION PROGRAM TO TEACH
OTHERS HOW TO GATHER OR PREPARE
ACORNS SEAWEED AND BASKET.
GENERAL'S THEY HELPED ME
CULTURAL ACTIVITIES DURING
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES DAY WHICH WE
CELEBRATE SEVERAL TIMES A YEAR.
WE DO OUR BEST TO MAKE OUR
STUDENTS FEEL VALUED AND ALL OF
WHO THEY ARE. IN CLOSING I'D
LIKE TO RECOMMEND THAT YOU
DEDICATE FUNDING FOR OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE TO CREATE A FRAMEWORK
AND ESTABLISH A PROCESS FOR
NATIVE AMERICAN CURRICULUM.
ADOPTION TO BE TAUGHT IN THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU TODAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WAS ROBBINS- M. LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT WITH THIS TO
HEAR WE HAVE JUDY FLORES SHASTA
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOLS.
AND CHAIRMAN- JACK JACK POTTER
THE TRIBAL CHAIRMAN OF THE
READING RANCHER A VENTURA
JOINING US TOGETHER BY WEBEX I
GUESS THEY'RE DOING THIS
TOGETHER TODAY. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER LAWRENCE SHASTA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AND
READY WHEN SHE WENT SHERMAN.
THE SHASTA COUNTY. CAN IN
BATTLES ROOM WAS FOR HIM TO WIN
THAT ARE STILL IN THE
CHALLENGES THAT STUDENTS FACE.
AROUND THE TENANTS. ALSO READ A
STOOD HAVE SOME. HIGHER OF
CRIME AGAINST. AND OTHER. FIRST
OF THE LAST FOUR YEARS OF
WORKING TOGETHER. I HAVE SO
MUCH FUN I TRIED. MONTEL AND
I'M AND OF THE CREW REP FROM
OUR AND LOCAL TRIBES REVENUE.
WHICH WILL TRY AND I'VE NEVER
COME. TO READ ENSURE THAT AS
WELL AS A TYPE SIX EDGY
PROGRAMS FEDERAL SCRIMMAGE.
FROM AMERICAN INDIAN AND CENTER
AS WELL AS AMERICAN AMERICANS
HAVE BEEN IN IN IN THIS. WE
ALSO INCLUDE IF YOU PUBLISH TO
COME SIDE LAST ON THE ROAD TO
ASSIST WITH THEM OR SOME AND
SOME. I ENJOY THE BALLOT
PURPOSE IS TO SUPPORT. AND
ENCOURAGE EFFORT SINCE IN THE
COMMUNITY. ACCURATE SURE OF
AMERICAN HIS. TO CORRECT MYTHS
AND MISCONCEPTIONS TO COMBAT
PREJUDICE IN PROMOTE
APPRECIATION AND TO CELEBRATE
AN HONOR. THE HISTORY CULTURE
AND- CONTRIBUTIONS. EVERYONE OF
AMERICANS. SWELLED WELL HERE'S
A BETTER SOME OF THE WORK
INVOLVED IN CLEARING. START. A
COMPLAINT WAS ON THE NEWS A FOR
ABSENCE ABSOLUTE THAT FIRST AND
HERE'S A RELIABLE STUDENT AND
SHE COUNTY AND MOST CAME OUT OF
A REALIZATION THAT CULTURE
EVENTS NOT SCHEME AB. AND NOT
ALL STUDENTS WERE. BETWEEN THE
NEED TO MAKE UP THE ROUTE THIS
LED TO A COUPLE OF ASSEMBLY
BANDS ADVANCED RECENTLY
ASSEMBLY BAD FIVE SIXTEEN
SPONSORED BY MEMBERS OF THE
STASHED YOU WEAR THAT WAS
SIGNED INTO THIS FIRE
EXPERIMENT WITH THAT PROMOTION
OF EXCUSED ABSENCES TO INCLUDE
CULTURAL EVENTS. WILL ALSO.
TRIMS WITH CARAMEL OFFICE STAFF.
AND OF. REDIFFMAIL ARE THE
BALLOT. WOULD SEEM TO TWO
HUNDRED EDUCATE. COMMUNITY
MEMBERS PURCHASE. TRAIN WE'VE-
I'M STORM THE REALMS OF. AND
PHONE. AND THIS IS GOING ON FOR
TIMES A COMBINATION OF THINGS
FACE YOU SEE ON THIS. NUMBER.
TIMES CARBON YEAH ADDITION.
STUDENT SESSION RIGHT TO TRY.
I'M KIND BIAS TRUE. FEDERAL AND
WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRIM ROOM FOR
PEPPERS. THE OF CLASSROOM
LESSON IS ANOTHER CA IN WE HAVE
WORKING ON LAST FROM IN GRADES
THREE FOREVER AND EIGHT AND
SHOWING INTO HIS I WILL PUT ON
TRUCKS CHILDREN SUBJECT OTHERS
AREAS AS WELL WE- ARE LOCAL
TRIBES TO CONTENT TO BE SURE
BUT SPECIFIC TO EACH TRACK. A
LOT OF MEMBER BETTER THAN
RUSSELL WITH RANGE TO A SHE IN
REACHED ASKED AND THE CONTENT.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
DEBATE OF THE ENVIRONMENT
POSTER. APPS ENJOY THE BETTER
THE BEST GOOD WITH NUMBERS FROM
INFO AND BRING THEM IN. TRIBES
WITH REGARD TO THE MAP AS WELL
AS THE RIVER F THE TIME. EACH
PER LIVES TO THE IN THE BROOM
IMAGE. SO IN OAKLAND. S. AND-
IN BATTLES ROOM ONCE THIS
TURNING LISTEN TO MEMBER WHO
WITH ME FROM. AND BIT MORE WITH.
THAT I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE AND
FACILITATE WE DISCUSSED WHAT TO
INCLUDE IN THE UPCOMING
TRAININGS. OPPORTUNITIES TO
SHARE CREATE ROUTINES AND
DISCUSS WAYS TO SUPPORT. THEM
TO TAKE STEPS TO SOLVE PROBLEMS
THAT ARE SHOULD. I AM GRATEFUL
FOR THIS AMERICAN TRIBES TO
COME TOGETHER AND BE WILLING TO
CONSIDER ORIGINAL PROOF. ITEMS
SPANNING OF YOUTH I WITHOUT A
GREAT VALUE EXTENSION AND
LEARNING FROM EACH ONE OF THEM.
WHEN THINGS ARE SMALL TEAM FROM
SHASTA CANNOT PRECIPITATION IS
STILL COMMITTED TO DO IS
FEDERAL THROUGH WITH WHAT WE
SAID WE WERE. TO SEE THIS MONTH
A REP MY FAVORITE I'M SO
THANKFUL FOR THE COMMITMENT OF
OUR TRIBES AND I REMEMBER
MEMBERS TO KEEP WORKING ON
IMPROVING OPPORTUNITIES AND
OUTCOMES FRIENDLY WITH HIM. AND
WITH THAT BAD TO REMEMBER TO
CHAIRMAN. JACK POTTER. GOOD
EVERY I'M WANTED YOU FOR YOU
KNOW ALLOW ME THIS BEFORE YOU.
IT'S A- YOU KNOW SOME OF GREAT
THAT YOU THAT WE BOUGHT FROM
THE WORK ON WITH OUR LOCAL
COMMITTEE. IS ALSO LOCAL TRIBES
HAVE BEEN MONEY TO COME TO AS
OF THE INDIAN FIVE THREE IN
SUPPORT OF ALL NATIVE YOU. OUR
NATIVE PEOPLE ARE CONTRIBUTING
LOCAL INSURANCE FOR EDUCATION
THROUGH GRANTS FROM GAMING
TRIBES. GOOD TIMES THAT LESSON
DEVELOPMENT AND THROUGH THESE
MONTHLY MEETINGS. I AM FAR TO
MOVE FORWARD. TOWARDS THIS BUT
DOING THIS WILL BE BETTER FOR
OUR GRANDCHILDREN. AND WE'VE
GOT YOU TO SHARE OUR NATIVE
CONNECTION TO THE WORLD AS PART
OF THE EDUCATION PROCESS. THIS
WORK IS OPENING UP DOORS FOR
NON NATIVES CAN BEGIN TO
UNDERSTAND OUR PAIN FILLED
PASSED. WE'RE ALSO CHANGING AND
CREATING A DIFFERENT WAY FOR
NATIVE PEOPLE SEE SCHOOLS FROM
BOARDING SCHOOLS TO BUILD
SOMETHING BETTER AND STRONGER
TOGETHER AND I PERSONALLY CAN
SPEAK TO I HAVE SEEN THE
CHANGE. I GREW UP IN SHASTA
COUNTY AND I. WANT SHASTA
COUNTY. AND I QUIT SCHOOL. YOU
KNOW THE BEGINNING OF SEVENTH
GRADE I JUST COULDN'T TAKE THE
ABUSE THAT WAS AT THE SCHOOLS
THE NON BELIEFS IN OUR WAYS OUR
TRADITIONS OUR CULTURE YOU KNOW
I HAD A LOT OF ABSENTEEISM
BECAUSE OF CEREMONY AND
EVERYTHING AND SO I'M GRATEFUL
THE STATE. AND THE I'M
REPRESENTATIVES HAVE PUT
LEGISLATION FORWARD TO ALLOW
THAT. IF WE COULD JUST EXPAND
ON THAT AND YOU KNOW MAYBE
POSSIBLY. GROW THAT WHERE WITH
A LETTER FROM THE TRIBAL LEADER
OR SOMETHING YOU CAN WRITE
SOMETHING TO THE SCHOOL TO
ALLOW THOSE CHILDREN TO GET
CREDITS. OR CAN BE IN THEIR
SERMONS IN CEREMONIES AND
THINGS AND SO THAT COULD BE
SOMETHING YOU KNOW THAT YOU ADD
TO THE BILLS THAT EXPAND ON
BECAUSE- THERE'S VALUE IN OUR
CULTURE. WE WERE AND I ASKED
THEM LATEST. AFTER LOCALS AND
ALL THESE THINGS WE ARE
SPEAKING A LANGUAGE THAT IS
FOREIGN TO ME I'M NOT ABLE TO
TRULY EXPRESS MYSELF WHEN I
LAUGH I LAUGH BECAUSE I WAS
TAUGHT YOU SHOULD LAUGH AT THIS
BUT I TRULY WOULD LIKE TO WHEN
THEY SPEAK. IN MY LANGUAGE YOU
GET AND HOW A HUMOR MY PEOPLE
GET ICING IN THE OLD PEOPLE
WHEN THEY SPOKE IN THEIR
LANGUAGE AND IT WAS A LOT MORE
YOU KNOW AND I BELIEVE WE'LL
GET BACK TO THAT EVENTUALLY.
BUT THESE BABY STEPS WE'RE
TAKING IS BENEFICIAL. AND ARE.
I DON'T KNOW WHICH IS IT IS
HARD BECAUSE SOME OF THE THINGS
WE HAVE TO GO BACK INTO AND
TALK ON. BRING UP A LOT OF THE
MOTIONS. THANK ARE. YOU KNOW
CHILDHOOD TRAUMAS INSTRUMENT I
WAS IN SCHOOL AND YOU KNOW. I'M
GOING TO. I SPOKE ENGLISH BACK
MY PRONUNCIATION AND SO I HAD
TO GO TO SPEECH THERAPY EVERY
DAY THERE WAS A LITTLE BAND VAN
OUTSIDE OF PROJECTS TO THE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND I HAD TO
GO OUT THERE AND HE I- APPROVED
AND YOU KNOW LEARN ONLY SOUNDS
AND STUFF AND I THOUGHT YOU
KNOW IT WAS KIND OF WEIRD
BECAUSE I LOOKED AROUND AND I
WAS YOU KNOW THIS LITTLE. BLACK
AND BROWN SKINNED INDIANS IN
THERE AND I THOUGHT WHAT'S
WRONG WITH CASH NOW I'M PRETTY
SURE SPEAKING ENGLISH BUT IT
WAS BECAUSE I SAID IN THAT.
STATE OF INDIAN. OR OVER THERE
INSTEAD OF OVER THERE AND NOW A
LITTLE BIT OF MY- INDIAN IS
THAT I HAD THEY TOOK FROM ME IN
THE SEVENTIES EVEN THOUGH I WAS
SPEAKING. ENGLISH MY DOCTOR'S
WORDS THAT ACCENT FROM MY
GRANDPARENTS AS THEY TALKED AND
SO EVEN THOUGH IT WAS ENGLISH.
IT WAS I GUESS EIGHT OF DIALECT
BUT THEY REMOVED THAT AND- NOW
YOU KNOW WHEN I DON'T HAVE MY
OWN PEOPLE BACK. I NOTICED A
DIFFERENCE WHEN AS I GOT OLDER
AND I WOULD TALK WITH THEM THEY
WOULD STILL STICK OVER THERE
THE INDIANS AND I WAS LIKE IN
THE END YOU KNOW AND I FELT SO.
AWKWARD AND IT MADE ME THINK.
THAT'S STILL WITH MY LANGUAGE
BUT YET IT WAS REMOVED BECAUSE
IT WASN'T APPROPRIATE AND AFTER
THE STANDARDS. AND SO I.
BELIEVE YOU KNOW WE'RE AT A
POINT WHERE. YOU KNOW. THESE
THINGS ARE BETTER FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR GRANDCHILDREN.
AND OUR ONLY GET BETTER AND I
WHEN I THINK THE CHEST CAN IT
RIGHT TO PUT IT IN THE IN THE
CLASSROOM WORK. FOR A LARGE
STEPS YOU HAVE TAKEN TO CHANGE
THINGS SHASTA COUNTY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATIONS WILL NEVER
GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ARE
THERE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE- FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MYSTERONS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND QUESTIONS- TO THE
PRESENTERS AND FAST AND- IT
CHAIRMAN- BUT I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY-
I'M HERE TODAY. WE HEARD AS FAR
AS RESOURCES TRYING TO
BUILDINGS RESTRICTIONS- FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AROUND
CALIFORNIA INDIAN EDUCATION AND
WHAT YOU. HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THEIR IN YOUR- ERIC
TORY WAS THAT MORE LOCAL TRAVIS
ALLEN A MORE LOCAL INPUT
PROVIDED THE RESOURCES TO BE
TALKING TO SCHOOLS. THE SERVER
AT REASON THAT START ACTUALLY
ON MY VERY FIRST OFF. AND I
HAVE DROPPED. WITH AT WALGREENS
WE END RIGHT C. RESTAURANT THE-
OUT EXECUTIVE AND GROUP INSTEAD.
SENT AND WE CAN IN AND SHE REST.
ONE TO CLOSE THE ROAD MAY BE
THERE IS A YOU SHASTA COUNTY
RETIREMENT ABUSE AND BOY OF
THOSE KIND SOUND AND MANAGED
AVERAGE A FEW MONTHS AFTER THAT
THE ROUND OF CHRONIC ABSENCE
DATA OUT AND THAT'S WHAT COUNTS.
I REALLY JUST BOB STATE IN
TERMS OF KIND ABSENTEEISM
BETTER LITTLE BIT STUDENTS ROSE
OVER 20% KEVIN RYLAND AB
CLINICAL ABSENT IN MID SUMMER
DISTRICTS WHEN IT WAS OVER 30%
I A CRITICAL ABSENT FAMILY OF
STUDENTS WERE TRANSFERRED. AB
AND THEN JUST BRING STUDENT
HERE LOCALLY AND SO WHAT I
WANTED TO LEARN MORE I AM SO WE
STARTED MEETING AND IT WAS JUST
REALLY INFORMAL AT FIRST TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND M. AND REP THAT
READ TO READ JUST OPEN UP AND
IT WAS GIVEN. ME A LOT OF
THINGS GOOD TEACHERS TO
REMEMBER STERN I ALSO THE
STUDENTS AND SEE THEMSELVES IN
THE PRINTER- INSTEAD AS WE HAVE
CHILDREN TO REFRESH YES THIS IS
IBM. THIS HAS EVER REALLY BAD
CONGRESO. WITH THOSE WHO SAID
OUR ROADS AND COUNTY AT
AMERICAN ADVENTURE GIVING INPUT
TO SAY. LIVES CAN. NEVER
PRESENTED WITH BEFORE AND AS A
REAL TRASHED I. WOMEN'S
TOGETHER. AND IT CAME TOGETHER
IN SUCH A POWERFUL. ST PETE.
THEN IN THE PLAN I AM SO YOU
KNOW EDS REMEMBER THAT RETRACT
TO WIN AT TO TAKE THEM THAT
HAVE BEEN WITH FIVE. TRUE DRESS
IN LOCAL. THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND DID YOU- REMIND ME- IN YOUR
TESTIMONY YOU MENTIONED THE-
THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
POPULATION WITHIN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SOUTH THAT YOU
REPRESENT. THE SIR I AM
REPRESENT SHASTA COUNTY
RETIREMENT FIVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN. ABOUT TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS OVERALL JUST
OVER 4% OF THE POPULATION. OF
THE COUNTY I HAVE STUDENTS.
THANK YOU- AND THAT MAKES UP
THE POPULATION OF THE SCHOOL
ITSELF ABOUT 4% NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS. THAT IS CORRECT. IN
TALKING ABOUT IT I REALLY DO.
ASSEMBLY BY ISRAEL SOME WAS MET
WITH AND SERVICE ANY THAT ONE
WORKING ON A TRYING TO HELP
THEM CENTERS WHAT CHECK. BOX
THE MINISTRATION FROM SCHOOL
THAT PUT INTO THE- OF OR MORE
RACES READ. AMERICAN AND THAT'S
WHEN I WE ARE EITHER RESEARCH
IS REALLY DEVELOPED IS. TO EACH
ONE OF THE SCHOOL AND SHALL
COUNTY THIS STE THERE'S SOME
BUTTONS SELECT. IF YOU REALLY
WANT TO BE COUNTY IN CONSIDER
IN I ABOUT STARTING AND THAT.
THANKS THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU
FOR THAT I ALSO- RESELLER THIS
LEVEL OF EDUCATION- WE SEEN IN
ROUND VALLEY THE HIGH
POPULATION OF NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS THERE WAS ANYWHERE
FROM 6270% OF THE STUDENTS THAT
WERE THERE SO. THE POINT IS TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT EVEN THOUGH WHEN
WE SEE THE DEMOGRAPHIC
POPULATIONS OF THE STUDENTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SOMETIMES IT IS BETWEEN 12%
THERE'S POPULATIONS IN THE
STATE THAT MAKE UP HERE IN THIS
CASE- OVER TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
STUDENTS NATIVE AMERICAN. IN IN
ROUND VALLEY IT WAS AS HIGH AS
7280% OF THE TOTAL POPULATION
SO JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT AND
BRING THAT FORWARD MISTER CHIP.
I JUST. MAYBE THIS IS PROBABLY
A QUESTION FOR THE
SUPERINTENDENT- IT DO YOU DO
YOU ANY SCHOOL SITES REALLY
THEY THEY ARE CONSIDERED A
SUBGROUP. YOU WHAT DO YOU WHAT
IS A HUNDRED STUDENTS TO BE A
HUNDRED STUDENTS OR- ANYTHING.
PLUS THIRTY PLUS. PLEASE CHECK.
YES WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF BAD
DISTRICTS THAT DO HAVE ENOUGH
STUDENTS TO BE COUNTED AS A
STUDENT GROUP. THANK YOU. BUT
AGAIN YOUR POINT BECAUSE IT
SOUNDS LIKE YEAH I THINK WOULD
YOU YOUR POINT YOU'RE TRYING TO
MAKE THEIR CONTENT THE STUDENTS
CONCENTRATED MAYBE TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN ACCOUNTING
BUT- THE NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATION AB CONCENTRATED. AT
CERTAIN SCHOOLS THIS. OPEN IN
THE IN THE COUNTY. AFTER THAT
WARRANTS THE FOR DISCUSSION OF
THE LOCAL- INPUT INTO THE
CURRICULUM AND THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE AT SHERMAN
POTTER WE TRIED TO MAKE A
COMMENT- YEAH I WAS JUST
STATING THAT I DO BELIEVE ALL
NUMBER IS LOW BUT STRONG- LIKE
OUR IHS A SERVICE AREA ACCOUNT
FOR A SHASTA COUNTY. WE HAVE
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND NATIVE
AMERICANS REGISTERED THAT ARE
HEALTH FACILITY. AND SO I'M NOT
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN WOULD HAVE.
YOU KNOW ABOUT SIX OR. SEVEN
THOUSAND SO THAT NUMBER TWELVE.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT- AND THE TESTIMONY THAT
YOU PROVIDED I FIND IT VERY
RESOURCEFUL AND AN EDUCATIONAL
WHAT'S GOING ON IN LOCAL AREAS
AND IDENTIFYING. SUBPOPULATIONS
THAT COULD WARRANT FURTHER
DISCUSSION THAT'S THERE-
SYNDROME YOU'VE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH- THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN DAY CONFERENCE AT CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY SAN MEDINA
WHICH WE ARE RUN- MYSELF AS THE
CULTURAL ADVISOR- FOR- THE
PEOPLE ASIDE THIS BEEN WELL
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. N.
N. WHAT WE FOUND DURING THAT
CONFERENCE IN ITS IT'S GEARED
TOWARDS THIRD AND FOURTH
GRADERS TO COME IN AND LEARN
ABOUT THE FACTUAL SIGHTS AND
SOUNDS OF CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE WE SHARE TRADITIONAL
SONGS. UBER'S SONGS BE
COURTSHIP SONGS AND BASKETRY TO
FIT INTO THE ARTS THERE ARE
THERE- AND TO DATE WE FIVE
EDUCATE OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
THIRD AND FOURTH GRADERS FROM
OUR REGION- WE ALSO SEEN- THE
NEED. TO THE CHAIRMAN'S-
COMMENTS AS FAR AS RESOURCES SO
WE INCORPORATED A TEACHER
CONFERENCE- AS PART OF THAT
CONFERENCE WHERE WE ACTUALLY
BRING NATIVE AMERICAN
EDUCATORS- FORWARD. TO BE ABLE
TO GIVE LESSON PLANS AND
APPROVED- THROUGH THE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE THERE FROM
THE INDIAN PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
BE USED IN THE CLASSROOM. CAN
YOU- TOP A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW
THAT IS INVOLVED TO FILL THAT
GAP AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AGAIN
BRINGING THOSE RESOURCES INTO
THE CLASSROOM- THERE IN THE SAN
MARINO ERIN HOW THAT'S EVOLVED
WITHIN THAT CONFERENCE. WELL
DURING THE- TEACHERS WORKSHOPS-
THEY LEARN. DIFFERENT WAY. TO
T. AND NATIVELY- THEY HAVE THE
BOOK THE PEOPLE OF THE PINES
AND THERE'S- CLASS LESSONS IN
THERE AND AFTER THE WORKSHOP
AND THE STUDENTS FIELD TRIPS
WERE. THEY ARE ALL EXCITED- I
GO WHERE IT AFTERWARDS AND-
TAKE THE LESSONS FROM PEOPLE
THE PINES OR- SOMETHING ELSE
THAT WE HAVE MADE UP WITH- YOUR
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT. AND
PRESENT THAT TO THE FORTY THIRD
AND FOURTH GRADE CLASSES. SO I
CONTINUED ALL YEAR. THE POINT
IS LIKE X. WHAT'S GOING ON IN
SHASTA COUNTY AS FAR AS A LOCAL
INVOLVED WITH THE LOCAL TRIBES
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT
THAT OUT BECAUSE- THE TIMES WE
TRY TO PAN AMERICANIZED. ALL
CULTURES ALL DIFFERENT- THINGS
THAT ARE THERE SO HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE'S IS
SO MUCH DIVERSITY DIFFERENT
LANGUAGE LIKE WE'RE SERRANO
MICHAEL WE HAVE. WE SAY HELLO
AND SERRANO DIFFERENT THAN WE
SAY HELLO IN CAREER. AND THE
SONGS ARE DIFFERENT MANY OF YOU
HAVE HEARD ME SING TRADITIONAL-
COOPER SONGS THAT WERE TAUGHT
TO BE FUN MR ROBERT LEVI THE
FATHER OF. THE FATHER LAW A
MERRY LEVI AND ROBERT LEVI THIS
THERE. BUT ALSO WHEN WE USE THE
HOST THOSE ARE FOR SERRANO
BEFORE SHE'D SUNG SO HAVING
THAT. THAT DIFFERENCE RIGHT. WE
CAN'T LOOK AT- ONE OVERVIEW FOR
THE STATE SAY HERE NOW. HOW YOU
TEACH ABOUT CALIFORNIA PEOPLE.
MAYBE THE RESOURCES AND GETTING
TO THAT COMPONENT. COULD BE THE
CURRENT AMOUNT OF LOCAL ALLEY
AS TO ENGAGE WITH THEIR LOCAL
TRAVEL PEOPLE TO BUILD THOSE
RESOURCES. THAT ARE THERE THAT
MANY TRIBES ALREADY DOING BUT
JUST HASN'T BEEN HIGHLIGHTED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO MAYBE THAT'S A
DISCUSSION COULD HAVE AS FAR AS
A CLEARING HOUSE ARE. SOMEHOW
WE LOOK AT THAT- BUT BUT IT IS
HAPPENING I JUST WANTED TO
POINT THAT OUT- THE THAT IN
SAMBAR DINO. WE DO HAVE PART OF
OUR COMPONENTS- THEY'RE
TEACHING AGAIN SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. I'M INVOLVED IN
THAT- BUT TEACHER- CONFERENCE
THAT GIVES MATERIAL TO TEACHERS
TO USE IN THE CLASSROOM. THAT'S
APPROVED BY THE LOCAL INDIAN
PEOPLE FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
USE IN THE CLASSROOMS. SO
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE BUT I THINK
THERE'S- A LOT OF WORK THAT
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER. TO ENCOURAGE THIS
THIS RESOURCES- CLEARING HOUSE
RESOURCES OR HOW YOU WANT TO
GET THAT INTO THE CLASSROOMS.
WHETHER IT'S AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
OR THE STATE ENCOURAGES THE
LOCAL DISTRICTS TO ENGAGE. WITH
THE LOCAL INDIAN PEOPLE SO
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WILL
FURTHER DISCUSS UP MR CHANNEL
WOULD BE OPEN. TO CONTINUING
THAT DISCUSSION. THANK YOU ARM
YOU MISTER. AND VERY MUCH A- I
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR PRESENTERS
TODAY- FOR PRESENTING ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC- WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT
MISTER DON. THE YEP BEFORE ON A
PUBLIC COMMENT I JUST WANNA
THANK- BOTH SHARES- MISTER
DONALD AND MR RAMOS. AND SAY
THAT IS AN EDUCATOR. AS AN
EDUCATOR IS A TEACHER FOR
THIRTY FOUR YEARS. AS A STUDENT%
BEFORE THAT AS A STUDENT IN
CALIFORNIA. WHO WENT YOU KNOW
K. TWELVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS MY FIRST TIME. THAT I
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THAT IN
ANY KIND OF DISCUSSION OF
NATIVE AMERICAN EDUCATION- AND
THAT IS CERTAINLY UNFORTUNATE-
IT WEEK WE HAVE REFERRED TO THE
PAST YEAR THE PAST SUMMER. AS A
SUMMER OF RECKONING. A WITH THE
MURDER OF GEORGE FLOYD I THINK
MANY. INDIVIDUALS THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES SEE THAT
EDUCATION CAN BE WHAT IT WAS
THAT WE NEED TO CHANGE AND SO I
JUST WANNA THANK- THE CHAIRS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. AND ALL THE
PRESENTERS AND I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK AHEAD OF US
BUT I ALSO WANT TO THANK- THE
LAST PANEL- CHAIRED A POTTER.
AND SUPERINTENDENT- FLUTTERS
FURTHER EXCELLENT EXAMPLE OF
WHAT CAN BE DONE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL- AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE HEARING IS THAT THAT'S
WHERE IT TAKES PLACE. AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND I WILL
CERTAINLY CARRY THIS WITH ME
WHEN I GO BACK TO RIVERSIDE
AND- AND SHARE THIS WITH THE
DISTRICTS IN MY- IN THE SIXTY
FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SO I
THINK THIS WAS POWERFUL AND
DISTORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
MEDINA. AGREED WITH THAT WILL
NOT GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT- WE
WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
FROM THOSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
FROM THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL OR THE TELEPHONE.
IF YOU WISH TO CALL ON THE
NUMBERS. 877-692-8957 THE
PASSCODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE.
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU ALSO FIND
THAT ON THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. ARE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC MAY ALSO SUBMIT
WRITTEN TESTIMONY. PUBLIC
COMMENT IS LIMITED TO ONE
PERSON I'M SORRY ONE MINUTE PER
PER PERSON ONE MINUTE PER
PERSON AND FIFTEEN MINUTES
OVERALL SO WILL START INSIDE
THE HEARING ROOM WITH COMMENTS
FROM WHAT ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
OF ONE MINUTE MAX- AND- AND
THEN WE WILL MOVE TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION AND THEN TO
THE PHONES FOR A TOTAL OF
FIFTEEN MINUTES WITHTHAT. OF
FOR IN ROOM- TESTIMONY PLEASE
COME UP TO A MICROPHONE ONE
MINUTE PLEASE THANK YOU. ON MY
HAS SHE AYE MARTY MAIDEN- LAKE
TAHOE WASHOE DESCENT AND
MONTELUPO. ARE YOU FROM YOUR
SANITY. I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT I AM A PRODUCT OF THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. I AM THAT LESS THAN
1% INSIGNIFICANT DATA. THAT'S
WHAT I GREW UP WITH CONSTANTLY
BUT I'VE HAD A FAMILY THAT.
ENCOURAGED US TO PROVE TO
OTHERS THAT WE COULD DO IT AND
WE WERE SUCCESSFUL. THE
CALIFORNIANS ARE SURVIVORS MOST
OF YOU KNOW THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA AND EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED IN THE UNITED STATES
CONDENSE IT IT ALSO HAPPENED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND SO WITH
THAT. THIS HISTORY CURRICULUM
MUST BE APPROVED AND BECAUSE
EVERYBODY HAS A CHIP ON THEIR
SHOULDER. FOR HISTORY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. MEAL AND MY NAME IS
ROBERT LEVI I AM A MEMBER OF
THE TOWARDS MARTINEZ BAND OF
COURSE THERE'S A CREATE INDIANS
FROM THERMAL CALIFORNIA. I YEAH
WHAT YOU GUYS ALL TALKED ABOUT
OF WHAT WE ALL TALKED ABOUT I
AM THE PRODUCT OF I TAUGHT AP
US HISTORY AND COLLEGE PREP U.
S. HISTORY FOR THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS IN THE UPLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH THAT THE
CURRICULUM THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
ESTABLISHED IN THE IN
CALIFORNIA IS DRASTICALLY
NEEDED. FROM WHAT THE
TRIGONOMETRY TEACHER DID LAST
WEEK TO WHAT YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT IN TERMS OF- MASCOTS IN
RIVERSIDE NOTICED- BRAVES IT'S
STILL THERE IN SAMBAR DINO
ABSALOM A BRAVES IS STILL THERE
WE NEED TO EDUCATE TEACHERS
STUDENTS PRINCIPALS
SUPERINTENDENTS EVERYTHING THAT
WE NEED AS CALIFORNIANS IN
TERMS OF THE CURRICULUM WHAT MY
WIFE SAID EARLIER. IS TRUE
WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN TEACHING
IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR ADDRESSING THESE
CONCERNS AND- COUNCILMEMBER
RAMA'S WE'VE COME A LONG WAY
FROM THAT DISCUSSION BACKYARD
OF MY. MY DAD'S HOUSE. THANK
YOU JUST. HEY ON HEATHER HOSLER
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN LEGAL
SERVICES AND A MEMBER OF THE
HOOP OF ALLEY TRIBE. AS WELL AS
MOTHER TO TRIBAL MEMBER
CHILDREN. AT THREE POINTS TODAY
FIRST POINT IS IT CERTAINLY IS
NOT THE LOCAL LEVEL. MIGHTN'T
DURING A OF MY CHILDREN'S
UPBRINGING I WAS IN SCHOOLS ALL
THE TIME SAYING THIS CURRICULUM
IS THAT RIGHT IT'S NOT FAIR TO
MY CHILDREN. THEY SAID IT'S OUT
OF OUR HANDS BUT YOU'RE WELCOME
TO COME DO A PRESENTATION. AND
THAT WASN'T THE ANSWER MY
CHILDREN DESERVE BETTER MY
DAUGHTER WAS CORRECTING THE
TEACHER AND THE PRONUNCIATION
OF OUR TRIBE HOOPA TRIBE.
SECOND POINT AT GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONSHIPS MATTER
LOCALLY I THINK WE HAD SOME
GREAT EXAMPLES TODAY FROM
SHASTA COUNTY. AS WELL AS FROM
THE HOOPA YUROK IT'S A NON WAY
AND KRUG AREA THAT AT MARGO
ROBBINS SHARED TODAY SO I THINK
THERE'S SOME GREAT EXAMPLES OUT
THERE. AS WELL AS OUR- OTHER
STATE FROM WASHINGTON. GREAT
RELATIONSHIPS UP THERE AND I
THINK THEY HAVE A PROVEN TRACK
RECORD OF WE CAN'T USE WORDS
LIKE ENCOURAGE. IT MUST BE
SHALL I THINK STATEWIDE
CURRICULUMS ARE IMPORTANT AS
FRAMEWORKS BUT LIKE ASSEMBLYMAN
RAMOS POINTED OUT. WE ARE NOT
MONOLITHIC IT NEEDS TO BE
APPLICABLE TO EACH REGIONAL
AREA BECAUSE OF THE DIVERSITY.
AND THEN MY THIRD POINT IS THAT
NOT ONLY IS KNOWLEDGE BUILDING
IMPORTANT IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM
I THINK THAT'S ONE APPROACH BUT
IT DEFINITELY THERE NEEDS TO BE
KNOWLEDGE BUILDING. FOR FOLKS
IN POSITIONS OF POWER. I'VE
BEEN APPOINTED BY TWO GOVERNORS
OVER THE LAST NINE YEARS WORKED
WITH INTELLIGENT. WONDERFUL
WELL INTENTIONED FOLKS WHO
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT TRIBES IS
GOVERNMENTS AND SIMPLY SUMMER
EDITION. I'M SORRY PLEASE
SUMMERS AT SO- WORKING WITH-
FOLKS WHO NEEDED TO UNDERSTAND
HOW DO APPROPRIATE LEE- MAKE
POLICY DECISIONS LAWS AS WELL
AS HOW TO APPLY- THE
INTEGRATION OF THE WORK TO WORK
WITH TRIBES AS MODERN DAY
FUNCTIONING GOVERNMENT OFTEN.
THERE TALKED ABOUT THE
HISTORICAL THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEANT- MEDINA.
PATRICK PATRICK SENATOR RAMOS.
I PRICE I'M SERGIO MARTINEZ
SEAT ONE OF THE CTA BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WHO REPRESENT MERY
LEVI AND ROBERT LEVI UP UPLAND
AND I BRING FORTH- THE QUOTE
FROM MY PRESIDENT TO EAT TOBY
BOYD WHO SAYS AS WE HAVE NAY
SAYERS AND CRITICS TO THE
EFFORTS THAT WOULD BE PUT FORTH
HERE. FOR TOO LONG WE HAVE HAD
TO FIGHT AGAINST RESISTANCE TO
TEACHING ABOUT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS AND PERSPECTIVES
OF PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY LOOK
LIKE MUCH OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THE STRUGGLE TO TEACH HONESTLY
ABOUT OUR HISTORY IS ONGOING WE
NEED TO STAND STRONG AND NOT BE
BULLIED INTO TEACHING A FALSE
HISTORY. TEACHERS MUST HAVE THE
FREEDOM TO TEACH. WE APPLAUD
YOU COMMAND YOU AND HELPING TO
TEACH THE TRUTH IN A ACCURATE
AND RESPECTFUL MANNER THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
STAND IN SUPPORT IN WHATEVER WE
CAN DO TO ASSIST IN GETTING
THIS CURRICULUM. BOB PUT
FORWARD FOR ALL OF THE CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. I
DON'T KNOW OKAY OKAY WILL DO
NOW IS WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE. AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. AGAIN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. IT APPEARS
NOW SO WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PHONES OF US THE MODERN
MODERATOR QUEUE UP A MODERATOR
IF THEY ARE- WAY OFF TOPIC OR
WE CAN'T HEAR THEM A PLEASE
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT CALLER-
EACH COLOR HAS ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AN
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU YOUR
LINE NUMBERS. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU DO WISH TO COMMENT ON
TODAY'S CALL. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE
LINE NUMBERS. THE OTHER THING
AMERICANS. I NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL
RIGHT GOOD MORNING SCHERING
YOUR MEMBERS I AM REALLY GLAD
TO HEAR THE DISCUSSION BROUGHT
BEFORE THE FLORIDA SO THAT LONG
OVER TO. ARE DISCUSSED BELOW-
MY ANCESTRY INCLUDES CURRY AND
CHEROKEE I LIKE TO SAY WITHOUT.
INTERNET INDIGENOUS TRIBES HAVE
OFTEN BEEN EXCLUDED FROM INPUT
IN OUR SCHOOL CURRICULUMS. WE
SURE THAT TEACHERS ARE TRAINED
APPROPRIATELY AND EDUCATING OUR
CHILDREN. AND THEIR CULTURE IF
I PROPOSED THAT EVERY DISTRICT
HIRE ADVISORS OR EDUCATIONAL
SPECIALIST. THAT ARE EITHER OF
INDIGENOUS BACKGROUNDS OR HAVE
BEEN POORLY EDUCATED AND
REGIONAL CHART. EDUCATION IS
KEY IN BREAKING THE STEREOTYPE
pBEING SPENT MANY HOUSE THAT
EVERY TRIBE ISN'T. WELL I CAN
ASSURE YOU THEY ARE NOT EACH
TRIBE HERE CALIFORNIA NEED TO
REPRESENT THAT EACH LETTER TO
ENSURE. THAT THEIR HISTORY.
CULTURE IF. INDIGNITY PLEASE
OKAY UP ON. AND OPPORTUNITY FOR
THESE LEADS. INTERNET ADDITION
PEOPLE PROBABLY AND WE THEY
WILL BE HEARD THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME MY NAME
IS A TOOTH DURING THE ON THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE WHAT RANCHERIA
LOCATED HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
LAST WEK RIVERSIDE COUNTY
TEACHER WAS FILMED MOCKING
NATIVE CULTURE AND LANGUAGE IN
THE CLASSROOM. WELL OUR LITTLE
REACTION MAY BE TO ATTRIBUTE
THE TEACHERS OUTRAGEOUS DISPLAY
TO A LACK OF INFORMATION AND
TRAIN WE KNOW BETTER. THIS WILL
BE QUESTION THIS IS A
DEMONSTRATION OF LOCAL
IGNORANCE AND THIS WILL
CONTINUE WITHOUT REAL
IMMEASURABLE CONSEQUENCES FOR
SUCH BEHAVIORS. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND IN THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I HAVE COME
TO EXPECT MORE FROM OUR
EDUCATORS ALIENATING NATIVE
CHILDREN AND CREATING BARRIERS
TO THEIR SENSE OF BELONGING
HAVE A DEVASTATING IMPACT ON
OUR CHILDREN AND LEARNING
OUTCOMES. I REFUSE TO TEACH MY
CHILDREN TO GROW CUTTING TO THE
MILLIE ATION. WE INVEST IN THE
MEASURE WILL NOT OF LOVE IN OUR
CHILDREN AND MILLIONS INTO THE
PUBLIC EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM I
DISTINCTLY REMEMBER MY MOTHER
FIGHTING FOR OUR RIGHTS TO BE
HEARD AND TO BE ACKNOWLEDGED.
OUR STANDARDS HAVE BEEN RAISED
WE WANT DIGNITY INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM. UNCLE
MORE. THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN YOU MAY PROCEED. HI MY
NAME IS CITY MASERATIS OBARA
AND I AM THE- DIRECTOR OF THE
AMERICAN INDIAN MOVEMENT SO CAL
TRIBAL CHAIR OF ROOFS AND I'M
NOT GOOD AT BY ONIE AND ALSO
HAVE SOME MAINTENANCE TO THE
CAPABILITY NO QUICHE NATION-
THE REASON I'M CALLING TODAY IS
REGARDING THE TEACHER IN
RIVERSIDE- BASICALLY MOCKED.
OUR INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. I KNOW
WE WERE OUT THERE LAST WEEKEND
THANK YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA FOR JOINING US- WE HAVE
ISSUED- LETTER HOPING THAT THEY
WILL RESOLVE THIS ISSUE WITHIN
THE NEXT DAY. OR SO AND WE'LL
FIND OUT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. BUT ALSO. ALSO I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THINGS LIKE
THIS NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN THIS IS
BEEN GOING ON IN THIS
CURRICULUM FOR SO LONG ALREADY
AND NOTHING TO BE SAD. I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS NEVER
HAPPENS THIS KIND OF-
CURRICULUM IS TAKEN OUT OF THE
CURRICULUM THIS KIND OF
TEACHING. AND JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT. IT DOESN'T HAPPEN ANYMORE
WE NEED- PEOPLE OF NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE PUTTING OUR
CURRICULUMS TOGETHER MAKE SURE
THAT THE TRUE HISTORY IS BEING
TOLD OF OUR PEOPLE. AND THAT
THAT IS WHAT GOES INTO THESE
PROGRAMS- TALKED TO THE REAL
PEOPLE OF THE TRIBES AND ALSO
ON THE OTHER THING I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IS THIS MORNING WHEN
A- SUPER- THE SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENT THURSTON-
INTRODUCED HIMSELF HE
INTERESTED HIMSELF FROM. COMING
FROM TONGA LAND WELL YOU KNOW
I'M OFFENDED BY THAT BECAUSE I
DIDN'T CATCH GAVE REALLY NO.
AND SO MANY PEOPLE BELIEVE THIS
IS ALL CONFIDANT DOWN HERE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW
THAT ALSO HAS TO BE CORRECTED.
IN THE BOOKS- YOU KNOW THERE
ARE SO MANY THAT ARE FORGOTTEN
BUT AGAINST TONGA THANK YOU SO
COULD YOU SUMMARIZE PLEASE.
OKAY THAT'S IN JUST I CAN SAY
THE TRUE HISTORY HAS TO BE TOLD
THE CORRECT HISTORY. AND NOT
JUST- WE HAVE TO LOOK INTO THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS TO THE NEXT
CALLER. ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS THIRTY
AS I'M FROM SACRAMENTO AND I'M
A MOM TO AN EIGHT YEAR OLD BOY
WHO IS IN FACT A PUBLIC SCHOOL
AND WHEN I THINK ABOUT WHAT I
LEARNED IN DIDN'T LEARN ABOUT
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AND MEETING.
PEOPLE AND CULTURE AND
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS
MYSELF I FEEL REALLY SAD AN
UNINFORMED AND WHEN I THINK
ABOUT MY CLASS FIELD TRIP TO
CENTER SUPPORT FOR INSTANCE I
FEEL JUST HORRIFIED AT HOW IT
WAS PORTRAYED IN HOW WE FELT
ABOUT THE SETTLERS AND WHAT WE
LEARNED AND DIDN'T MIND. AS I'M
REALLY HOPING FOR BETTER FOR MY
SON AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT HIS
TEACHERS ARE EQUIPPED WITH
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE AND
SENSITIVE AND FACTUAL
CURRICULUM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. TO THE NEXT CALLER. AND
LADIES GENTLEMAN THERE ARE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
SO WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
IN THE QUEUE GOT IT THANK YOU
LORI I'M SORRY WE WITH I'M
SORRY WE DO ACTUALLY HAVE ONE
PERSON THAT THAT CAME IN LAST
MONTH. IT WAS LIKE THIS AST
ONE THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE.
NINE TWENTY NINE. OKAY THANK
YOU MODERATOR. THERE'S NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS IN THE QUEUE
GREAT WILL SPRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- I JUST WANT TO THANK
ALL THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED
TODAY WHETHER HOME WATCHING-
THE PRESENTERS TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE INFORMATION
YOU SHARED WITH US TODAY IS
VERY VERY VERY VALUABLE VERY
IMPORTANT VERY STARK- SINISTER
MEDIA HAS CITED AND I ALSO
WANNA THANK MISTER RAMOS WHO'S
REALLY THE LEADER OF THIS
EFFORT. AND ARE GO TO ON IT-
FOR PROMPTING THE US TO HAVE
THIS HEARING TODAY A LOT OF
GOOD INFORMATION WITH THAT ANY
FURTHER COMMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE- PRISONERS AND ALL THE
TESTIMONY THAT'S BEEN- PROVIDED
HERE TODAY. I JUST WANT TO-
REAFFIRM THIS THE EXAMPLE THAT
WAS DONE BY AND SENATOR MCCOY'S
GRANDSON AS FAR AS KNOWING-
ORCA AND THE NATIVE AMERICAN
LANGUAGE FOR A KILLER WHALE BUT
YET THE- THE EDUCATOR INSISTED
THERE WAS ONLY ONE RIGHT
ANSWER. RIGHT FOR THAT IN ORDER
TO. MOVE THAT FORWARD YEAH AND
THAT THAT'S- SOMETHING THAT
RESONATES WITH A LOT OF- INDIAN
PEOPLE NOT ONLY. HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
THROUGHOUT THE NATION- MYSELF
INCLUDED. WHEN WE WERE GOING TO
OUR LOCAL ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
AND- WE CAME FROM THE
RESERVATION. I WANT TO THERE.
AND. THEY PLAYED A DRUM SONG.
MUSIC AND THEY SAY WHO'S- NAME.
RAISE YOUR HAND WE RAISED HAND.
AND IMMEDIATELY ASKED US TO
INTERPRET THE DRUM SONG- OUR
CULTURE WE DON'T USE DRUGS SO
WE SAID WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
IS THAT'S NOT OUR MUSIC. AND
THE PERSON THE EDUCATOR AT THE
TIME SAID WELL SIT DOWN YOU
MUST NOT BE INDIAN ENOUGH. SO
THAT STILL IS GOING ON HERE
TODAY AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR ALLOWING.
US TO HAVE THIS- THIS HEARING
HERE TODAY AND HIGHLIGHTS. THE
NEED THAT IS STILL OUT THERE TO
FURTHER THE EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENT OF NOT ONLY THE
TRUTH. IN THE CURRICULUM BUT
THE RESOURCES TO BE BUILT THAT
TEACHERS CAN BE EQUIPPED TO
TEACH THOSE IN THE CLASSROOM.
THESE I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT
THAT THESE TYPES OF- PERSONAL
STORIES THAT YOU HEARD TODAY.
AREN'T JUST OF THE PAST THERE'S
STILL HAPPENING TODAY IN OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEM. THERE'S JUST
SOME THAT HAVE NOT COME TO
LIGHT- JUST LIKE THE SITUATION
AND RIVERSIDE THAT HAS COME TO
LIGHT NOW. EVEN THOUGH IT'S
BEEN REOCCURRING. HOW MANY
OTHER DISTRICTS ARE STILL-
AFTER SEEING THOSE TYPES OF- OF
ACTIONS. THE SOMEONE OF THANK
YOU AND FURTHER IN THE DIALOGUE
AND FURTHER IN ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE AS WE MOVE. FORWARD I'D
LOVE TO CONTINUE THIS DIALOGUE
SO THAT WE COULD CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD. THIS TYPE OF- OF
ACTIVITIES RIGHT TO HIGHLIGHT
AN ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE IN ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE WHOLE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
ONCE WE LEARN THE TRUE HISTORY.
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OF
WHAT HAS HAPPENED WHICH
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN IT ONLY
MAKES US ALL STRONGER AS ALL
CALIFORNIA. GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND I SHOULD ALSO- I.
KNOW THE HARD WORK OF MAKING
THIS HEARING HAPPENED AND-
GETTING OUT THERE COMMUNICATING
P. WITH PEOPLE IS OUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT EDUCATION COMMITTEE
TANYA LIEBERMAN. WHO DID A
GREAT JOB OF PUTTING PUTTING
THIS TOGETHER AND ALSO BOB
BECKER- FROM THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND SUPPORT
MAKING TODAY HAPPEN. MISTER
MISTER RAMOS A STAFF AS WELL I
SHOULD NOTE THAT I'M NOT SURE
THEY'RE OUT THERE SOMEWHERE.
BUT OR THE HEARING IS RIGHT OW
I DO A GOOD JOB ALL OF YOU ALL
OF YOU SO WITH THAT I THANK YOU
ALL. FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION IN
A.